this is Joo podcast number 56 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Eko good
evening silent screams and Broken
Dreams addicts junkies pushers and
fiends crowded spaces and sad faces
never look back as the police chase us
consumed Slowly by chaos a victim of the
streets hungry for
knowledge but afraid to
eat a life of Destruction it seems no
one cares a Manchild alone with burdens
to
Bear trapped in a life of crime and hate
it seems the ghetto will be my
fate if I had just one wish it would Sur
L
be that God would send angels to set me
free free from The Madness of a city
running
wild free from the
life of a ghetto
child and that is a
poem written by a
young DeAndre
Mulla a criminal drug
dealer who when he wrote that po poem
was doing
time after being one of the main
subjects in a book called The
Corner which is written by David Simon
and Edward Burns which
documents the violent drug trade in
Baltimore
Maryland and that sort of morphed into
an HBO series that was called the corner
as well which paved the way for another
series which is called the wire which is
just an
outstanding miniseries that came out on
HBO but the wire is is fictional even
though it's based on kind of the the
same situation in Baltimore but the
corner is real the book The Corner is
real and it gives a very clear and a
very Grim
view at the life of drugs and crime in
the inner
city namely in Baltimore and I'm going
to go back to the book
now we can't stop
it not with all the Lawyers Guns and
Money in this world not with guilt or
morality or righteous indignation not
with crime Summits or task forces or
committees not with policy decisions
made in places that can't be seen from
the Lost corner of FY and
Monroe no lasting victory in the war on
drugs can be bought by doubling the
number of beat cops or tripling the
number of prison beds no peace can come
from Kingpin statutes and civil civil
forfeiture laws and warrantless searches
and whatever the hell else is about to
be tossed into NE next year's crime bill
down on fat Street they know today as on
every other day the shop will be open by
midm morning
and the TS will be on the corners
chirping Out product names as if the
stuff is street legal the runners will
bring a little more of the package down
and the fiends will queue up to be
served a line of gaunt passive
supplicants stretching down the alley
and around the
block the corner is rooted in human
desire crude and certain and immediate
and the hard truth is that all the law
enforcement in the world
can't mess with
desire down at FY and Monroe and every
corner like it in Baltimore the dealers
and fiends have won because they are
legion they've won because the state of
Maryland and the federal government have
imprisoned thousands and arrested tens
of thousands and put maybe a 100,000 on
parole and probation roles and still it
isn't close to
Enough by raw demographics the men and
women of the corners can claim victory
in Baltimore alone a city of fewer than
700,000 Souls with some of the highest
recorded rates of intravenous drug use
in the nation they are 50 perhaps
60,000 strong three of them available
for every prison bed in the entire state
of
Maryland the Slingers are Manning more
than 100 open air Corners serving up the
product as fast as they can get it off
the southbound metr
liner and the fiends are chasing down
that blast
247 in neighborhoods with where no other
wealth exists they've constructed an
economic engine so powerful that they'll
readily sacrifice everything to
it and make no mistake that engine is
humming no slacking profit margins no
recessions no bad quarterly reports no
layoffs no naturalized unemployment
rate get it straight the not just out
here to sling and shoot drugs in drug
market and in cities Across the Nation
lives without any obvious justification
are given definition through a simple
self-sustaining
capitalism the corner has a place for
them every last Soul touts Runners
Lookouts mules stickup boys stash
Steelers enforcers fiends burn artists
police snitches all necess necessary in
the world of the
corner each is to be used abused and
ultimately
devoured with unfailing
Precision it's about the fiends
thousands of them who want that good
dope they need it the way other Souls
need to breathe
air it's about the Slingers the young
Crews working the packages all of them
willing to trade a moral
that they've never seen or felt for a
fleeting moment of material
success they are working the package
with the hidden knowledge that they will
fall that with reare exception the money
won't last and the ride will be over in
six months or four or
three
violence violence is no longer the
prerogative of the professional but a
function of impulse and
emotion The Contract Killers and the
well-planned assassinations of earlier
eras are mere myth on these
Corners now the Moment of Truth
generally comes down to some man child
with hurt feelings waving a 38 a 38
around spraying bullets up and down the
block the accidental shooting of
bystandard is now Common
Place
even 15-year-old Hoppers have loaded 38s
hidden in the alley the job is little
better than a death
wish and in the end the corner best
serves the hard car the hardcore the
junkyard dogs with neither the time nor
the inclination for
pity the corner proves itself every
day it destroys whatever it
touches and
eventually the corner destroyed DeAndre
McCulla even though he received the
Second Chance in his life and he
actually got to play a small role in
that series that came out on HBO The
Wire you got some other jobs in the
entertainment industry as well but the
corner called them
back and that guy DeAndre who wrote that
poem he ended up dead of a heroin
overdose in 2012 at the age of
35 now there's a reason I'm bringing all
this up and that is because we have a
guest tonight
a guest that is
actually more responsible for this
podcast than anyone and we'll get to
that
later but his name is Peter
AA and he grew
up a boxer he been a longdistance
endurance
athlete got his degree in medical
engineering and Applied
Mathematics and then got his Doctorate
as an MD from
Stamford and did his residency
in
surgery and the reason that I started
off this
whole
talk about the corner is because he did
that residency at a place called job
John Hopkins
Hospital which is about three miles from
the actual corner of FY at Monroe
Street the war zone that's pictured in
the book the place where DeAndre McCulla
lived lived and where violence was and
in many ways still is just a part of
life and Peter was at Ground Zero in the
war
zone and saw more darkness and suffering
probably than any person should have
to and learned a lot from
it and we're going to get to that in a
bit but first of all Peter
AA welcome to the show thank you for
having me sir glad to have you on
finally
and you grew up we'll get we'll get
right into it you grew tell us a little
bit about just growing up you grew up in
Canada and I know you've covered for
those of you that hasn't listened to the
Tim Ferris is interview with you listen
to them what is there three of
them yeah I think so I think there's
three of them you can listen to those
and get more details on you know Peter
his whole background but for those that
are just listening right now you grew up
in Canada just a little little little
statement about that yep I grew up in
Toronto um you know immigrant parents so
grew up you know sort of in the
wonderful lower middle class uh not the
best suburb of Toronto there Toronto
like New York has five burrows four of
them are nice one of them is not I grew
up in the one that's not so nice um and
uh meaning it's just a dump not like
it's you know it's not like a war or
anything
um and I have lived now in the United
States for about half my life so I High
School in college was in Canada and then
everything from med school Beyond has
been here and I am now a dual citizen of
both countes how did that transition
work because you didn't you you
obviously got Applied Mathematics
degree and then you worked in the
civilian World a little while with that
degree right yeah so uh my plan was
always to do a PhD in Aerospace
engineering um and so I that's why I did
the mechanical engineering and applied
math I did the two things for undergrad
got it and then was sort of just in the
almost about ready to go and start that
PhD in Aerospace and then I had a just a
complete change of heart and decided I
wanted to go into medicine and so that
so what I had to do for a year then was
you got to take this thing called the
MCAT which of course I didn't have any
of the courses to take it so I had to
sort of teach myself the chemistry and
biology that summer took the MCAT but
then I still a lot of times that's what
I do in the summertime is I'll I'll
teach myself you
know chemistry and biology I didn't I
didn't do that well and then uh and then
I had to do what's called a postback
year where you go back and you're in the
process of applying to medical school
without actually having the courses to
get in so if you get in it's conditional
and and so that year because I'd already
graduated I just taught calculus um so I
you know was like a you know adjunct
lecturer at the University and taught
calculus which I I always enjoyed I mean
because i' taught it for a couple years
before and so and so that's why you're
waiting to get into med school applying
and then and getting my courses like I
forget what I had to take biology and uh
psychology biochemistry I had to take a
few prerequisites to get in because in
engineering and math I'd never taken a
single course in fact the day before I
took the MCAT this this is only going to
be funny for Geeks Who get biology so
I'll clarify but that won't be me yeah
I'm studying for the MCAT this Summer
that I'm supposed to take the test and
the whole time I'm studying I'm like you
know I I can't believe how sloppy these
textbooks are they keep confusing
meiosis and mitosis like why can't they
just spell it the same way both times
like they I didn't realize that it was
two separate things right meiosis is
when a cell separates separates the but
doesn't replicate its DNA mitosis is
when it creates an equal copy and I
literally not until the day before the
MCAT realiz I that those were two
separate things I mean that's how that's
how clueless I was going into this test
which I was Lu Reon I knew that was CU I
was helping one of my daughters study
for their biology something so anybody
who took any biology course should know
that but but I hadn't taken any so so
then you get in med school yeah you go
there what's that four years another
four years of school uhhuh and then you
get done with that and now it's time to
do your residency so you do you get to
pick where you're going to go not sort
of so it's a funny system called the
match system so when you're in
your guess you're beginning your fourth
year of medical school by that point you
have to figure out what you want to do
do you want to be a surgeon do you want
to be an internist do you want to be a
pediatrician a radiologist whatever you
want to do because all of those have
different
programs and then you have to apply to
those programs so let's say you wanted
to do orthopedic surgery you would send
out your application to all the
orthopedic programs in the country
hopefully you'd get interviews to a good
number of them you'd go do the
interviews and then you would submit to
a match system a rank order of the
places you'd want to go and you don't
put something on there that you don't
want to take so if you if you interiew
you know if you applied to 30 programs
you got interviewed at 15 and you liked
10 you rank those 10 in order similarly
the programs after they interview
everybody do the same exercise they do
the rank and then a computer matches you
one to one that's actually pretty
squared away yeah so you the only way
you're going to guarantee you know where
you're going is rank one program and
hope you get it so um in my case I for I
think I ranked five
programs um and I ranked um John's
Hopkins first for surgery not because I
wanted to live in Baltimore though in
many ways I think it was a blessing to
to do so but you know
because at the time I don't know that
this is true today but at the time it
was probably the best general surgery
training program in the country and that
was a combination of two things one is
you had these kind of legendary surgeons
there that had pioneered some of the
most complicated what are called
hepatobilary surgeries surgeons you know
surgery of the pancreas and the liver
and stuff like that but at the same time
as you alluded to it was in a war zone
and so the other aspect of training to
be a good surgeon is having great
exposure to penetrating trauma so trauma
you always want to divide into blunt and
penetrating blunt trauma is not often
operative so people that get hit by cars
and things like that you know it ends up
being more Orthopedic but if you're a
general surgeon and you need to be able
to cut open the chest and the abdomen
and things like that it's penetrating
trauma it's it's you want knife and
gunfight um not that you want it but
that's that's the training ground to be
in so and and sort of Baltimore would
have been you know probably in the top
five was
this 2000 2001 yeah 2000 I think okay
and when you were what was the what was
the thing that slipped or this is going
backwards a little bit what was the
thing that transitioned in your mind
where you all of a sudden wanted to do
medicine well yeah it's funny I don't
think I've ever talked about this
publicly um so when I was in engineering
school I uh in my second year I started
doing some volunteer work um and I this
the reason why is too complicated but I
started volunteering
with uh some kids that were in in a
shelter that had been abused so it was a
it was a home for sexually abused kids
and that got me interested in sort of
volunteering in a hospital so I was
volunteering at a hospital that um had
you know it was a pediatric uh Cancer
Ward so you would just sort of you know
you'd go up there and you'd kind of hang
out with kids and just play with them
and stuff like that and so between that
experience and then I was still doing
this volunteer work with these kids who
had been sexually abused a lot of those
kids were suicidal so I also found
myself in the hospital a lot with these
kids after they'd attempted to kill
themselves and I think somewhere in my
senior year of engineering I kind of had
this you know I I don't know what the
word is you know I don't think it's an
existential crisis as much as maybe a
nervous breakdown but just a bunch of
things were kind of going on probably
some undiagnosed psychiatric issues on
my part but I realized
like I love engineering and math
intellectually but I there's no
emotional connection outside of the joy
of solving a problem which by the way is
probably plenty enough but I wondered if
there was something else that I'd be
more interested in that could scratch
two itches right it could scratch sort
of the intellectual itch but also maybe
an emotional itch and so I spent the
majority of my senior year thinking
about was there something else I ought
to do um but I'd been successful in in
my undergrad so it was sort of a given
that you know if you're going to
graduate at the top of your class you're
going to go off and do the best PhD
program so at the very end when I sort
of declined to do that and I turned down
a bunch of
scholarships um it seemed a little odd
that I would go and do medicine but but
that's really the reason it was you know
kind of this Epiphany I had one day
actually uh while I was in the hospital
and I was sort of had this actually it's
really funny we just moved as we talking
about earlier and you know one of the
things moving is great for is cleaning
up stuff and I actually found my essay
that I wrote when I applied to medical
school back in you know whatever 95 or
96 and uh it was really interesting to
go back and read the story because it's
exactly kind of how I remembered it
right which was like this moment I had
this sort of insight this is what I
wanted to do so um so that's that's kind
of the the the the series of events that
led me to have that seemingly orthogonal
change in
Direction okay so now you go through
that you end up you you get your
accepted to your residency at John John
Hopkins you show up there what what's
that like well I remember when I I
interviewed at Hopkins for medical
school as well um and I was lucky enough
to get in there for medical school and
at the time I think Hopkins was
technically the best medical school in
the country I think it was Harvard and
Hopkins were the best two and Stanford
was you know maybe third 4th fth but I
remember when I interviewed there for
medical
school at the end of the interview like
I had to spend a night there and so they
put us up in the dorms for The Med
students which great idea you get to
meet your upper classmates and I
remember I said that Friday night I said
hey I'm going to go walk down to the
harbor it's like a mile and a half down
the road and they were like oh no no no
you can't do that I said what do you
mean they said you you you you can't
walk outside of the hospital and then
they pointed out that on every corner
corner there was like a booth with an
armed guard there's a guard in full
armor with uh an automatic weapon and so
I remember at the time thinking yeah I
probably don't want to go here for med
school so and of course Stanford sort of
for a guy who'd never been to California
and who'd lived in miserable cold
weather his whole life I was like it
could have been the H hundredth ranked
medical school I was still going there
yeah I have some actual stats that I
pulled up so War Zone in 1993 there was
48 murders for every 100,000 people
there's what 700,000 in the in the city
the next highest was in
2015 55 and in 1993 again there was 353
homicides homicides yeah almost one a
day and so you know I have to put this
in there just you know because we're
sitting here calling it a war zone so
when I was in ratti in 2006 the 11 ad
which is the the ready first brigade you
know 5,000 600 soldiers while we were
there with them for 6 months they lost
61 guys
so what I'm saying is now that doesn't
count the enemy casualties but it counts
the friendly casualties that are showing
up at our med center right so there you
know you're talking three or 400 well
you just said one a day yeah about one
one a day okay
so um so you knew how bad it was when
you got me you already I yeah I sort of
knew it was dangerous but but I think
when I decided that you know for this
That season of my life you got to
sacrifice everything and you have to go
to the place where you're going to get
the best training and I didn't want to
leave California because you know four
years in California for the first time
was you know I mean you know you guys
know what it's like I mean it was like I
don't ever want to leave this place but
I also knew I just couldn't get that
level of training on the west coast and
it was you know you basically had to go
to a place like Hopkins beram and WB in
Boston maybe washu in St Louis was going
to offer a very similar environment um
so then you know so then I ended up
ranking it first they ranked me first so
away we go we get lucky it's a match
made in heaven and that's like kind of
February of your senior year and then
reality sits in which is you've got sort
of four months until you have to show up
and that was kind of like the oh
moment right like that I really just
signed up for this um and a good friend
of mine who was two years ahead of me in
medical school his name is Brian Dunham
he's now a uh pediatric head and neck uh
ear noos and throat surgeon at chop in
Philadelphia he was at Hopkins which was
at the time the best ear noos and throat
program in the country and he actually
recommended I read this book The Corner
because and Brian's one of these guys
who's just you know he's just he's like
a renaissance man you know like not only
he's a great surgeon he's like a gifted
artist you know his side job is medical
illustration
like you can't believe what this guy can
do but he's introspective right and he
was he said look you know you're you're
going to sign up to be in this war zone
and you're going to be taking care of
people that it's going to be very easy
to
despise so he said you need to read this
book to gain a sense of their
perspective um because very like I said
you know so so at the time I I can't
remember the stats I feel like at the
time that I was there we averaged about
16 penetrating traumas a day now to put
that in perspective in general surgery
you're on call every second to every
fourth night so average about every
third that means every third night 120
times a year you will spend the night in
the hospital not
sleeping waiting to take care of any
trauma patient so if every third day and
night you know 16 of these people are
getting shot and stabbed you're going to
have a lot of time in the ER in the
trauma Bay dealing with with that and
it's really easy to get jaded really
quickly it's fun for the first month and
then all of a sudden every time somebody
gets shot it's preventing you from
sleeping which when we're sitting here
all well rested sounds like a very
callous thing to say but all of a sudden
you're sort of like damn it man like I
can't eat because the trauma pager just
went off again to this day I still eat
shockingly fast and it drives my wife
nuts but she doesn't understand I said I
I think it's just I'm a victim of you
never know when you're going to have to
stop what you're doing and that might be
your last meal even I shave quickly
because the worst thing that could
happen is you got shaving cream all over
and the trauma pager goes off and you
got to run down half shaved you you got
one side of your beard done the other
side so it's stupid things like that so
so that was Brian's recommendation so I
got the book immediately devoured it
found it to be the most depressing thing
I had ever read it it's heavy um made
more depressing by the fact that they
pull no punches no names are changed so
every person you read about you are
reading about it in a completely
uncenter uncensored unfiltered way and I
mean you you read it you know there's
nothing happy about this book like you
just finish it and you think yes you
have more empathy and you understand
where where these folks are going to be
coming from but it's like I don't there
it's not like you finish that book and
go ah here's the solution we need a
Sixpoint plan that's going to do XY it's
like I je that's kind of why I read that
one excerpt it's like we can't win which
is an awful thought and that's what
that's the impression the book gives you
is is we can't win and I that the the
way he phrases it of being L it doesn't
matter how many police and whatever you
do you're you're going against human
desire well the the stat that you
reiterated and I remember it very well
from when I read this book the first
time was you couldn't take every junkie
and put them away if you took every
federal and state prison bed in Maryland
you'd have three people for it if you
just looked at the users never mind the
guns the money and everything that comes
with it so yeah that's not a solution
now there's a second reason that I don't
think Brian knew because I don't think
anybody knew that that book really hit
home which um was it's it's it's it
sounds tangential to this story but it
becomes highly related in at the
beginning of
uh end of my third year of medical
school I'm going to the gym one day
riding my bike as I always do I get I
get to the gym I get off my bike go to
lock it up and I was like my back really
hurts like really hurt not like oh it's
a little stiff like something feels
horrible so I started walking down the
steps of the gym and I was like not
going to happen today like I mean I
couldn't I couldn't do anything I
couldn't time my shoot so I just went
back got on my bike rode rode back to my
apartment told my roommate I was like
hey man I'm GNA kind of go lay lay down
upstairs the next morning I woke up I
couldn't get out of bed and to make a
very long story short over the next two
weeks I completely deteriorated um you
know I was at the point where I could
get in and go to the hospital but I had
to like have the nurses this is back in
the wild west days where you could just
sort of get anything you needed at the
pharmacy you know I'd get nurses or
residents to inject Tor doll into me
which is a really strong end said I
could only sleep if I laid in an L shape
over the nurses station um and it just
wasn't getting any better and then one
day it the pain changed immediately I
realized in retrospect what happened a
herniated disc had fragment had broken
off so the pain in my back dissipated
but now I had this what turned out to be
a 4 cm fragment sitting on my S1 nerve
rout so now it felt like my left foot
was being skinned from the bottom but
that was constant so that was an
unrelenting pain and it could only be
sort of brought under control if I could
put my foot into a bag of ice CU then I
could make my foot go numb and then I
could take some pain medicine so this
went on for another week and then the
dean of the medical school saw me
limping through the hospital he said
what's wrong and I told him and he
dragged me down to the ER we got a MRI
that showed all of this and I was in
surgery the next morning um this was a
Sunday night Monday morning I'm in the
O it turned into a disaster the guy who
operated on me operated on the wrong
side
so I woke up the left issue was still
present but now I had what's called a
foot drop on the right side so foot drop
is when the nerve that holds your foot
up which we take for granted when we
walk but if you don't have the ability
to what's called dorsiflex um your foot
would drop you can't walk you'll end up
dragging your toe when you keep
tripping this story I mean we could
spend three hours on the story because
it's so idiotic the punch line is I
eventually needed many trips back to the
operating room this guy refused to
believe there's anything wrong with me
it took another amazing doctor a
neurologist to actually intervene on my
behalf and 3 months later I'm unable to
walk I'm unable to do anything my mom
actually had to fly down from Toronto to
look after me um and I'm sort of you
know you go through the the checklist
right so so there's I don't know if
you've ever heard of Elizabeth Kubler
Ross I don't think she's alive anymore
but she wrote a
very famous book on the stages of dying
and it goes through like anger and
denial and finally acceptance at the end
right and so you know bargaining like
it's something that would make sense if
you and I'm sure you've watch heard of
that before and you've probably watched
it on really small scales you know like
in combat you might see these things
over the course compressed and dealt
with it and with a cancer patient you
might see this stretched out over a year
and so I was kind kind of going through
this on my own right where initially it
was like oh my God what if I don't
finish this rotation I'm doing right now
what's called a surgical sub internship
to oh what if I don't graduate on time
to what if I can't be a surgeon and then
it was what if I don't walk ever again
um so somewhere along the way and I
don't remember exactly
when probably like a month and a half
into this I finally caved in and started
taking pain medicine I I I thought
that's where the story was going I was
like at some point he's going to get on
the OPI yep and I had been so reluctant
to do so initially been so stoic you
know just taking my nids and um even
using benad dril which is a horrible
pain medication of course but it sedates
you through some of the
pain and so I you know I started taking
Percocet and peret is um it's typically
10 Mig of oxy Co so oxycodone is the
fast acting version and it's stronger
than say a so a Vicodin is Tylenol and
hydrocodone immediate acting but
hydrocodone is not as strong as
oxycodone so Percocet is stronger than
Vicodin they both have Tylenol it's just
the opiate is stronger and so you know
if you take a peret which would have 500
milligrams of Tylenol and 10 Mig of
Oxycodone you know I probably was taking
you know you start taking two three four
five six of those a day you develop a
tolerance and
eventually you there's a a longer acting
version called Oxycontin which is just a
time-released version of
Oxycodone so then you would take that
twice a day so at my Peak I was probably
taken 80 Mig of Oxycontin a day plus
another 120 milligrams of Oxycodone I
just got rid of the Tylenol Al together
you can just get straight
oxycodone and so I'm about 200 Mig a day
of
Oxycodone equivalent and again if you
know if I took that today I would just
die you just stop breathing but at the
time you know you build up this
tolerance but it also there was this
point where I
realized that I wasn't just taking it
for the physical pain right and I think
this is the single most important
Insight I had that when coupled with
reading that book 6 months later was the
I think the single most important
realization I ever had with respect to
to this problem which was at some point
it was I was just so depressed that I
couldn't walk and I was so worried that
you know I'd never be able to do
anything again that at least the drug
gave me a high that took me away from
that and so then it got to the point
where I was just taking that drug all
the time and I just stopped engaging
like wasn't engaged with anyone anything
um and then I sort of had this
realization that that was happening and
I was like I I want to stop so at the
time I was was dating um this girl she
was an anesthesiology resident so she
was a few years older than me re just
the coolest coolest person and I said to
her she was kind of the only one that
knew what was going on because at the
time even the doctors who were
prescribing this like this just wasn't
on people's radar as a problem back then
I think today people would be like
homeboy got 200 milligrams of OxyContin
a day that's probably not good but at
the time it was just like it was like
Tic Tacs right so that would
legitimately kill like if I took 200
milligrams would that would really Jack
someone up I would think I think if I
took 200 today I would stop breathing
yeah CU that's how opiates kill you they
repress they they inhibit respiratory
drive that's what whenever whenever
someone overdoses on heroin they just
stop breathing um so yeah I think 200
would I don't know we'd have to I'd have
to look at the farm we don't have to
actually take your word for it on this
one um so the girl you're dating she she
said you can't just stop right you the
withdrawal is so
painful that you have to taper off you
have to probably go on methadone and
then you'd have to start some pretty
potent
anti-depressants um like maois or TCA so
you have to go on a drug like
nortryptiline which is in of itself kind
of a crazy thing and I was like yeah but
I think I'm just going to stop cold
turkey now unlike alcohol so if you took
an alcoholic you know you took someone
who's drinking 20 alcohol you know
alcoholic beverages a day and they've
been doing that forever and you stop
them they will die they will get
something called delirium tremens and
they will die a horrible cardiac death
they will break into AR rhythmia and
they will die so when we had alcoholics
in the hospital let's say we had to
operate on somebody who happened to be
an alcoholic we would actually just put
them on an ethanol IV we weren't even
trying to detox them we just wanted to
make sure they didn't die and go into
these delirium tremens but but heroin
and opiate is not like that it is not
physiologically lethal to stop cold
turkey it's just
unbearable and so I was like I'm going
to do it so against her better judgment
I just stopped one day and she could not
have been more right it was the darkest
I mean I can laugh about it now it was
the darkest month of my life it was a
month oh at
least I mean it was I would just sit on
a park bench for the whole
afternoon like complete flat affect but
it's all mental it's not a physical
thing no there's physical stuff going on
I mean but but no it's it's yeah you you
know you you sort of like you know
opiates make you itch like crazy you get
constipated so there's like a reversal
of a whole bunch of physical stuff but
the biggest thing is the craving and the
depression um and so the depression of
coming off this thing was
brutal um in many ways and I don't tell
that story to say well look at how
special I am that I detox that's not the
point at all I had two things going for
me that virtually no juny has going for
them right the first is I didn't have a
network of people around me that were
doing the same thing so I was sort of
the only guy doing it so for me to go
and be around my friends was to be
around people who weren't doing this we
always used to joke that if you really
want to kick a heroin habit you have to
get a whole bunch of new friends like
you you don't get to decide you're not
doing heroin and then go back and hang
with your friends that are doing heroin
you they need to watch train spotting to
learn that the second thing and perhaps
the more important thing is I finally
did connect with a doctor who was able
to put me on the right path so I I had
ended up going back to the operating
room probably half a dozen times over
the course of the year to have all these
problems corrected and then I found
something else to fixate on which was
physical therapy so I started to you
know even though it didn't seem like
exercise it wouldn't seem like exercise
today at the time it was the first
activity I was able to do and so you
know within 6 months I could like walk
like a reasonable distance again and so
I would be spending 3 hours a day at
physical therapy just doing like the
most trivial exercises but basically the
root cause of my depression was getting
better so that's really the only reason
I think I was able to kind of detox off
this stuff whereas I think for many
people a it's not clear what the root
cause is or B it's not getting better if
it is clear and so that's why I think
it's really it's a it's a brutal
addiction and it seems like also you're
you had a a future right you had a life
you were in medical school you're going
to you know you're going to do something
where a lot of these people that are
drug addicts what do they they have no
life that they're looking forward to
they're just looking forward to nothing
absolutely and so in February of that
senior year when I had to submit my rank
list I think we match in March I
misspoke
earlier I was still not functional
perfectly like there was no way in
February of 2001 that I could have
withstood a surgical residency but I had
to make a decision at that point which
was will I be ready on July 1st and if I
won't be I should not submit my rank I
should defer a year sit out a year of
medical school whatever and I remember
that was the hardest decision I to make
and I just gambled I was like you know
what I'm going to be ready and I'm going
to make it happen no matter what and so
I submitted matched and then in addition
to now reading the corner to prepare for
Baltimore and reflecting on my own sort
of struggle with addiction which was
completely fresh in my mind I'm also
like rehabbing like it's my day job and
going through like as and I most people
take the last quarter of med school off
but I didn't have the ability to do that
now because I had to I had to go
straight through till graduation day
because I'd missed so much time during
my injury um so when I showed up in
Baltimore a couple of days before July
1st I mean it still wasn't crystal clear
to me that I could go you know two days
without sleeping standing in O for8
hours at a time all those sorts of
things now that's one of the things you
the sleep deprivation CU people always
obviously I take a lot of flak cuz I
don't sleep a lot and and the sleep
deprivation so what did that look what's
that like when you're going through
residency and you're just saying I mean
there's days where you're going 24 48
hours no sleep and how did that affect
you what did you think of that what do
you think looking back at it what's your
opinion of it now well you know when I
decided that that I was going to go into
surgery I mean I I always I'm I'm pretty
uh insecure in general most people don't
necessarily appreciate that on the
outside but always thinking I don't know
if I've got what it takes here how do I
figure it out and and so my my whole Mo
in life is test the system hard so when
I was in medical school still deciding
this I figured well every Thursday night
I'm going to pull an allnighter in my
room standing up not allow myself to eat
sleep drink pee do anything and I'm
going to stand at my desk for 8 hours
and practice suturing you know sort of
try to mimic what it would be like to be
in an operating room all night not being
able to go pee not being able to drink
not being able to do this thing and so I
had a little bit of confidence you know
I figured okay I can do this like I can
pull an all nighter once a week that's
you know not that that's a good thing to
do but it was like kind of a confidence
thing right so then you show up but
there's no preparing you for what you're
in store for now I got to point out this
is not the way it is anymore so in 20
I want to say like
four um it's almost like labor laws came
into exactly they a whole bunch of laws
came in that we could spend hours
talking about how it turns out the laws
haven't they haven't fixed the
underlying rote problem but nevertheless
a whole bunch of work requirement hours
stuff got fixed right so you couldn't
work more than 80 hours in a week or 88
depending on if your program had an
exemption and you couldn't work more
than 24 hours consecutively and stuff
like that that but by the time those
laws really kicked in I was already gone
and and so I don't really know what it's
like today but I would imagine it's um
it's less demanding from a sleep
deprivation standpoint but at the time
there were no such rules and you were at
the sort of every second every third or
every fourth night call but then your
post call day you would still work so
our mutual friend Kirk parsley which of
course is how we met this is one of his
favorite stories about
me he loves this story cuz it's so crazy
so this
is July of 2001 so I am one month into
being a doc right and I'm on an every
third night call rotation at this
hospital called Bay View which is about
5 miles from what we call the Mother
Ship which is Hopkins and it's out in
like East Baltimore it's in a real
crappy part of town not that there's a
really I mean I hate saying this but I
there not that many good parts of town
at least back then in Baltimore um and
uh so I'm uh so I show up on a Monday at
5:00 in the morning so I I slept in my
own bed Sunday night so Monday morning I
show up at 5: to round we do our whole
thing
and that night I'm supposed to go home
so that's my off that's called your
swing day you show up at 5:00 you'll be
home by 7:00 p.m. that night if all goes
well so you work your you know 14 hours
and then you sleep in your own bed and
then you get to come back the next day
and then you're going to be on call so
the so we're rounding that afternoon so
and the uh one the the one of the senior
residents says Hey so and so didn't show
up for their shift in the ER the the ER
always staffs one surgical resident
full-time and this guy just didn't show
up and she's like and it's a 7 p.m. to 7
a.m. shift can you cover it
and you know this would be like if you
asked the most Junior guy you know to do
something like he he he'd be kicking his
own ass to say yes like he couldn't wait
to do that right so I was like hell yes
I will do that so then I go down to the
ER and I work all night 7 to 7: and then
the next morning is now my on call day
so now I'm 700 a.m. cranking away until
that night and then I'm up all night on
call so
and then it's now Wednesday and it's my
post call day and I'm there till 5 or
600 p.m. so I've basically been up from
about 4:00 a.m. Monday and it's now 5 or
6:00 p.m.
Wednesday and I get in my car to drive
home and I have to make it I have to go
down this miserable street called
Eastern Avenue to hit the 83 to drive up
to my place and um I'm driving along
Eastern Avenue which is is like red
light after red light after red light or
stop sign or whatever and every time I'm
at a stop light I fall asleep my foot
pops off the clutch and I stall like I
am so tired I can't even you know handle
like the gradual you know easing off the
clutch and the gas just to move up and
up and up I can't do it so finally in
one moment of lucid Clarity I'm like you
can't get on the freeway you're going to
die so I was like what's the solution I
was like you got to get over and take a
nap so I pull over my car on the side of
Eastern Avenue right in front of this
park called Patterson Park which at the
time I don't think I fully understood
that that was an open a drug traffic
market so I got out but here's the best
part of story The Logical thing to do
would have been just been stayed in the
car and take a nap but I was like you I
haven't seen the sunlight in like days
and it's the sun is still out like I'm
going to go nap in the park so I get out
of the park I'm in Green scrubs that are
covered in you know blood stains cuz I
was too dumb to not change I go lay down
in the park I take my pager off and I
clip it to my neck and I set the alarm
to like go off in 1 hour you know so at
like 700 p.m. it'll wake me up and I'll
feel perfectly rested and I'll be able
to drive home so I lay down in middle of
Patterson Park and the next thing I know
I wake up it's like 1: in the morning 2
in the
morning there's needles everywhere
there's I have like bites on my arm that
look like they're from rats cuz they're
like nothing I've ever seen before like
these bites all over me and I'm just
thinking to myself like how did I not
get killed here like the only thing that
prevented me from dying was how
ridiculous the site was you know if
something's so strange like nothing you
know so I was like God damn it man so I
get back in my car and drove home and
when I tell Pary that story he loves it
because he's like that's the classic
example of how complete deprivation of
sleep impairs your judgment um so you
know there were a couple stories in
residency where I had to do like those
three night back to back to backs
another time it happened I remember was
in ' 05 did you feel like though okay
driving a car is kind of boring right
stop lights but when you're really tired
but then all of a sudden something
happens like boom I feel like when that
happens I feel I can lock on there's
almost no amount of sleep deprivation
that will stop me from functioning and
getting something done that's important
on task on time absolutely is that true
do that true for yeah no I think I think
an adrenaline rush in the moment can
provide any amount of clarity and focus
that's necessary the problem is very few
things are life or death that way now in
your world there were plenty of things
but in my world not and this is the
actually other story I was going to tell
was in uh probably my third
year uh I think it was my third year um
I was same same sort of deal I ended up
covering for somebody and then covering
for two people and two consecutive
nights and then it was my turn so now it
was like three straight nights of not
sleeping and it's the middle of the
night and this guy comes in the ER who's
you know got a really diseased
gallbladder and in retrospect it should
have never come out that night but a lot
of times the Dirty Little Secret is
surgeons want to operate at night
because they can get better o time
electively as opposed to waiting the
next day if it's not emergent so sure
enough we're in the middle of the
operating room doing a laparoscopic
gallbladder removal at 2: in the morning
when we don't really need to be there at
2: in the morning we could have slept
and done it the next day
um and sure enough so so in in removing
the gallbladder is a two surgeon
procedure so there's the main surgeon
which because we're at a teaching
hospital I'm the main surgeon I'm
actually doing the operation and then
there's the attending who's holding the
camera and retracting for me so I'm you
know like I'm doing this and yeah that's
a stimulating activity but of course
I've done a hundred of them so it's not
that stimulating well I can't stay awake
and I finally somehow managed to fall
asleep on this patient like I face plant
into the patient wow luckily it was
laparoscopic so I didn't contaminate the
surgical but so even something as
stimulating as surgery cuz look if the
guy's aorta was bleeding I'm sure I
would have yeah exactly but all you were
doing is pulling out pulling out his
gallbladder is no big thing yeah yeah it
wasn't stimulating enough to overcome
three days of sleep debt did you do did
you figure out any tricks any you know
for instance I can when I was going
through Seal training and even my whole
career and even to this day I take these
I take little power knots if I'm feeling
that tired I elevate my feet and I sleep
for like six to eight minutes and it
totally recharges me did you do you take
power
naps no aside from your power nap Park
that lasted 7 hours and almost got you
killed I did I once took a power nap in
my car again same thing I was like it
was like 8:00 at night I got to the pool
I had a rule which was after you left
the hospital you never went home because
I knew if I went home I wasn't going to
leave so I would always go from the
hospital to the gym or the pool or
whatever I was doing and on this
particular night I get there it's 8:00
at night I am so tired I'm nauseous like
the thought so you didn't want to go
home just because you knew you'd go home
go to sleep you didn't want to go to
sleep because you've been awake for
three days why didn't you want to why
didn't you want to go and fall asleep
well because you know it's really funny
a good friend of mine who again couple
years ahead of me gave me interesting
advice whether it was right or wrong I
don't know he said look you're going to
be tired no matter what in Residence
don't stop doing all the other things in
your life because you'll still be tired
now I don't know that that was the right
advice but I took it to that advice and
my view was I'm going to continue to
work out every day I'm not on call I'm
going to you know do all the stuff I
want to do and unfortunately sleep
always took the brunt of it so yeah so
it would be to the pool and so same
thing I got there but on this particular
night I was so tired I was so nauseous
like I couldn't suppress the desire to
vomit and I was like I'm not going to I
can't if I puke in the the pool they'll
kick me out I won't get to swim it's
just not going to be worth it so I was
like just sit here for like 30 minutes
and take a quick nap so same thing took
the pager out which normally could wake
me up clip it here and it was freezing
cuz it was like the winter so I
left no it wasn't cold but I remember I
wanted to leave the radio on like a
dumbass so the car is off so
alternator's off radio's on well you
know how the story ends I wake up at 2
in the morning battery's dead I'm in the
middle of the parking lot I can't you
know
had to call my girlfriend to get jumper
cables to get me out that's a one that
girlfriend went on to become my wife by
the way um so short answer no I didn't
have a great strategy I did have a
friend who and I never tried this but he
told me he would put coffee grounds in
his eyelids and apparently it hurt so
much that you couldn't close your
eyes you know that's I mean I would not
that but I've told people this all the
time too you know do do a little bit of
physical exercise if you're super tired
that definitely picks you back up
there's got to be some reality or some
scientific reason for that happening so
that's another thing you can do but um
so you so okay we know it sucks you're
not sleeping and you're dealing with
these patients and and how do you start
to
detach from this reality that's around
you so you're not getting you know CU
you said already you like kind of the
emotional involv with people but then at
the same time you said it didn't take
long before you despise these patients
that are coming in because they're
interrupting your sleep and bothering
you that's got to be a crazy balance to
try and strike as a human being I mean
human beings are not meant to be dealing
with 16 puncture wounds a day that's
that's not right so what what happens in
your brain what happened in your mind
what did you notice about your mentality
in this whole business as time went on
well what I noticed so again not
everybody becomes jaded but most people
do and where where my sense of jaded
developed was actually towards you know
the patients with diabetes the patients
who had complications from being
overweight like when those people would
show up with you know the absis in their
foot in the middle of the night that
needed to be de breeded those people I
would get again pretty pissed at
amazingly the what we you know these
these trauma folks like I kind of always
maintained a soft spot in my heart for
them and
interestingly you
know it's it's it's e once they die so
so what happens is like let's say a guy
comes in guy's been shot um you know
generally people who are dead in the
field don't make it in so so but but
sometimes there's this gray Zone where
you know someone comes in who's
basically dead but because they had a
little bit of a pulse on the way in the
door like we're going to do everything
we can but a lot of times when those
patients die like the room has to be
turned over really quickly which means
someone's got to come in take the body
put it in a body bag gather everything
because usually these are criminal
investigations so the police are there
the housekeeping staff has to come in
and mop all the blood off the floor
because depending on where the gunshot
wound was like gunshot wound with the
head for example tons of blood um
because the head's a confined space um
and in that moment it's really easy to
just immediately walk out the door but I
find myself you know i' sometimes like
flip through their wallets right and you
know invariably you'd see something like
you'd see a picture of a little kid so
you you see this guy who's huge who's
just been killed he's probably 25 and
you'd see like this six-year-old girl in
his wallet and you you know you'd start
to sort of wonder what the narrative is
right like was that his daughter
probably did he know her probably did
she know him maybe not like you just
don't know and all of a sudden that that
that stuff sort of humanizes these these
guys and and again I think because of my
own understanding of what they were
dealing with cuz of those 16 penetrating
traumas 15 had to be drug involved in
one way or
another um and so everybody who were
taken care of for the most part was some
part of the cycle that's being described
in the corner now occasionally it
wouldn't be I mean one of the examples
that stands out that was I would say
sort of like the top five saddest things
I ever saw in residency was July 1st 20
2 I just happen to remember that day and
this girl on her 16th birthday came in
and she was just she was just hit by a
stray bullet in her neighborhood it was
her 16th birthday stray bullet from you
know unrelated gang violence hit her in
the head and you know she's an example
of someone who came in basically dead
but in situations like that like you you
know I'm sure you can relate to this
you're just going to do something that's
so beyond heroic you want to do anything
and everything to try to save her and of
course we couldn't so you know those
examples are are kind of rare but the
majority of the times it's you know
executions for people who stole money
um that's those those would be hard to
see right CU you can these are you know
this is like this is a deadly game even
the even the girl the 16-year-old girl
she's part of the cycle too because
that's just a stray bullet that's right
she's in the she's in a lousy
neighborhood you can almost guarantee
that you know if she's living in where
she's living to get hit by a stray
bullet like you know yeah she wasn't
living in you know Roland
Park and when once you did you would you
ever see any family would any family
ever come
in yeah so there's two types of things
going on right so so the the biggest
problem we would have would be real gang
on gang stuff
because it became sort of a feed forward
Loop right so if one guy came in and he
was
killed you immediately knew the
floodgates were going to open because
there was going to be retaliation that
night I don't remember the police were
pretty good about trying to make sure
that like when someone came in and who
was killed like if you weren't immediate
family you were not allowed there um and
they also tried to create a little bit
of a delay in letting that information
out again maybe that wasn't the the the
most considerate thing to do but their
view was trying to let the violence
dissipate um yeah the family stuff's
hard I mean the hardest family
interaction I ever had was with a was
with a actually a blunt trauma and it
wasn't involving drugs at all right this
was a this was a um a boy he was 15
years old he and his brother his older
brother who was probably 18 had picked
him up after school they were driving
home and they were they had the right
away and a guy ran a red light and
T-boned them on the passenger side and
this the 15-year-old boy both of them
came in as separate traumas but the
older boy came in as an adult trauma so
he went to the adult side I happened to
be on pediatric surgery like I was the
uh senior resident on pediatric surgery
that month so I ran the Pediatric trauma
which is where the 15-year-old came in
and the turned out the older the driving
son was fine he didn't have a scratch on
his body but this kid came in basically
dead on a Ral though it wasn't clear why
but his pupils were blown um you know
little bit of a pulse we did you know
probably 30 minutes of everything
imaginable before accepting the reality
that he sheared his aorta so if a a high
enough force can actually Shear the
aorta and it dissects and you basically
bleed to death inside the wall of the
aorta and that's why he died and that
was another example of how everybody
just sort of scatters after that but you
know his mom is in a waiting room
wondering where her boys are who you
know could have been an offender Bender
for all she knows
so th those were
I mean unquestionably the most difficult
discussions ever because trauma is the
one area
where there's complete surprise like it
you know it's tragic when somebody dies
from cancer it's even tragic when
somebody dies during an elective
surgical operation which happens
unfortunately from time to time but at
least there you have some heads up that
something dangerous is going on but this
kid like you know said goodbye to his
mom that day went to school and never
came back and now she hears oh he's in a
car accident and she's in the hital
Hospital never imagining that he could
be dead and then you have to be the guy
that goes in and say you know I'm really
sorry to tell you this but your son is
dead you know there's actually a really
interesting article written in the New
York Times on this exact topic um by uh
so it's kind of an interesting story so
my mentor in medical school to this day
one of the closest mentors I've ever had
is a guy by the name of Steve Rosenberg
so Steve Rosenberg is the chief of
surgery at the National Cancer Institute
um and he's kind of one of The
Luminaries in immunotherapy so I did my
postto with him at the NIH and uh I
actually spent time there in medical
school and actually he just called me
yesterday out of the blue we ended up
having a great catch up for 30 minutes
his daughter he has three daughters his
youngest daughter is Naomi Rosenberg
who's uh a resident at in I think she's
an emergency room doc at Penn which is
also in a war zone in Philly and she
wrote a great piece on this which maybe
we could link to in the notes or
something um it's probably like the last
3 months about the difficulty of having
to communicate to families when
tragedies like this happen which of
course you you know she would see a lot
of as well in
Philly and then that happens so you do
everything you can to save this kid's
life and then you walk in you face the
mother you drop the most devastating
possible imaginable news on her
you got to go back to work I mean right
I mean don't you then have to isn't
don't you have to go work again now yeah
that that night in particular that was
you know that was that was um I I
remember that day pretty well that was
April of
2003 um when that boy died and um by the
time you know by the time we had
declared time of death and I had gone to
talk to his mom it was probably like
10:00 at night you know I probably spent
an hour with her and of course it's
disruptive because you're in there and
your page is going off I've got the ER
calling me about this kid and I've got
the ICU calling me about this and you
know um and she's you know I mean like I
I don't I I God I sure hope I never have
to know what she went through because I
can't can't really imagine right I mean
she's hysterical at a level that you
just like a movie doesn't do justice to
that like you don't see that level of
hysteria normally um and I I that that
was certainly like one of kind of the
three or four that really upset me the
most I mean I I had a real hard time get
I think I got lucky that night I think
that night ended up being a pretty calm
night I remember I got to probably spend
some time just alone in a call room that
evening you know and and for me that was
a so the this is the awful thing here is
we tend to project what's going on in
our own life into any situation I mean I
I think I realized that pretty early and
so I think in the case of that
particular trauma I saw in that boy my
brother my younger brother and so I so I
was dealing with two things in that
moment one
was um meaning from my own end not not
not the immediate issue which is this
boy died one is I'm imagining now like
this could have been me and my brother
in high school like this this could have
been Us and how how your life changes
after that like I thought his brother's
life is never going to be the same um
the second was this was already after I
had decided to leave medicine
altogether um which was in June of 2006
and this this trauma was like April of
2006 I decided in March of that year
that I was just going to finish that
year and then leave so so the other
thing that was sort of that I was
struggling with which probably makes
this a little heavier than it needed to
be
was as painful as this is It's a
privilege to be this person it's a
privilege to be the guy who gets to try
to save a life and even when you
fail that interaction you're going to
have with that family which I think is
something Naomi wrote about in that
piece it's so important it seems trivial
to us because you have that interaction
over and over and over again but to that
family it's so important that will be
with them forever and I think I felt I
felt that that was a privilege and so I
think I realized like I'll never do this
again I'll never again have that
privilege to even if I fail to to try to
you know sort of Save Somebody to
actually then be able to um comfort that
family and and that sounds really weird
it's a very morose sort of thought to
have but all of those things I think in
that particular example um you know made
for a really difficult uh set of you
know days and weeks that followed I went
to his funeral as first patient I ever
went to a funeral of a first trauma
patient certainly went to the funerals
of patients you got to know through you
know people who were dying of cancer and
stuff but you know trauma patient like
you just wouldn't think to go to
someone's funeral that you'd never known
cuz like I'd never known the boy right
um I stayed in touch with his mom for a
few years and not surprisingly their
life just completely fell apart you know
does it does it make it that much worse
that you got this you juxtapose the the
kind of this normal kid right who dies
this random accident and then at the
same time every night you're you got
people that are killing each other
and you're dealing and you're seeing the
results of that and you can't do
anything about it how does it does that
also play into your your thoughts about
hey I'm here trying to save these
people's lives and they're out there
killing each other for over nothing over
the street corner over this over that
did you go down that road
mentally not there I'll tell you the one
time I felt really ethically maybe
ethically is too strong a word but just
to be blunt I mean the one time I was
really pissed off that I was trying to
save somebody's life was a guy that came
in who killed his wife killed his
daughter and then put the gun in his
under his chin and pulled the trigger
and missed so he basically blew off the
side of his face and was still alive his
brain was completely intact this guy was
going to survive after 23 you know face
operations and and you know I'm taking
care of this guy in the ICU and I'm kind
of pissed off about it actually right
and and maybe I shouldn't be right who
am I to judge this guy but I'm like you
know you killed your wife you killed
your kid and you wanted to die why the
hell am I putting anything into you now
of course that is a slippery slope
because in medicine we're never supposed
to play that role right we're never we
never play God right people you know
some doctors want to act like they're
playing God but we never play God we're
just there to do a job and on that day I
remember think I don't want to do this
job I don't want to I don't want to take
care of this guy I want this guy to die
actually how do they how do they how do
they address that when you're going to
medical school that whole idea they've
got to cover it on so or is it just so
underlying the underlying theme of
everything you do that by the time you
get done you're it's there that's a
that's a really good question I I don't
know the answer e are there ethic CL
ethics classes in medical school that
teach you that I am sure there are I the
fact that I can't tell you one thing
about an ethics class I took tells you
it's that whatever ethics you have are
going to be independent of whatever
class you're taking and who knows you
know today you know these pendulums
swing from one end to the other for all
I know you know half the curriculum
could be ethics today I I don't know but
but the short answer is I think you know
it's it's sort of internal and the
reality of it is you know if you're in a
good program and the one thing I'll say
I mean as much as Hopkins was a brutal
place to exist the camaraderie there was
unbelievable I mean you know the
nickname for the residents was the
Hallstead Marines right which again
doesn't do justice to real Marines but
that was sort of the camaraderie right
it was like you would do anything for
your res you know that's why you'd
always volunteer to stay up three nights
to help somebody else out and so you
know I had really great friends there in
fact to this day like some of my closest
friends people that I'm in touch with
almost every day were were guys I went
through that experience with and you
could talk about those things with each
other right I mean you know it was it
was okay to say like I really wish this
would die um cuz he's
taking up a bed he's costing the state a
million bucks and I hate him um and I
somehow being able to talk about that I
think makes it a little bit easier right
well absolutely I mean any that's what
happens in the military you get guys to
go through tough situations tough
battles and they OB they become closer
going through it and part of the thing
that brings them closer together is
you're talking about what's going on as
it's happening and after it happens what
did
you so a lot of times in this this
podcast I say that this
podcast yeah we talk about war and we
talk about leadership and we talk about
history but I find that the actual root
of what the podcast becomes about is is
really about human nature and what
people what human beings are
like was there I'll give you both sides
of this question did you learn anything
about people about human nature there
that was surprisingly
positive and before you answer that one
did you learn anything about human
nature while you were there that was
surprisingly
negative
so so I'll give you one thing that I
learned that I don't know that I would
call positive or negative but it was an
observation that in retrospect seems
obvious but it never would have I never
would have thought of it before and to
this day it still serves me well to
understand it so the obser the F this is
the first observation is that
um when you look at a significant
illness like a a a a completely
disrupted
insult you know cancer you you know you
have pancreatic cancer which means
you're going to die and you're going to
die soon um there are two types of
families that come into that situation
so families that show up already
fractured get blown apart fractures that
families that show up already tight
become the tightest of any family the
same would be true when you see you know
a kid that comes in you know a burn
victim right this kid that gets burned
badly on the 4th of July and this kid's
going to spend the next two months in
the hospital um you know a couple that
comes in with tension already in their
marriage they get splintered wide open
if they came in and everything was fine
they're going to be there for each other
they're going to be tighter so so that
was an observation that I just saw over
and over and over again and I saw it in
probably even more um Vivid color when I
was at the NIH because the the two years
I was there um you know I was mostly
doing research but you still had
clinical responsibilities and so you're
you're basically seeing patients who are
coming to receive experimental therapy
for cancer so these are patients who are
all you know otherwise going to die
within six months and most of them will
still go on to dial obviously a subset
of them we can help but you're seeing
that over and over again so that was the
first observation and then the second
was that there were just a couple of
residents who um I couldn't believe how
amazing
they could be who how how they could
never sort
of do the wrong thing so so there were
two residents in particular one really
he was he he his name is Chris sand he
is now a uh he's a transplant surgeon at
the University of Michigan amazing guy
and so Chris was two years ahead of me
and I mean he was like that guy that I
would have done anything for and I
remember when I was leaving thinking to
myself
you know I'm really glad I'm leaving
because if I stayed I'd know I could
never be as good as Chris like that like
how can someone be this good and I don't
mean like he can sew this good and cut I
I don't mean even medically good human
being just as a exactly as a human being
he is on a level I can't get to
and you know I don't know anybody else
who can get there either but the fact
that I can't get there is a little
upsetting to me um and I'm glad I don't
have to spend the rest of my life
chasing
him which of course Chris would never
think of it that way because that's the
nature of being that guy is you he's
just completely humble modest unassuming
guy who just happens to be a
God you know it's it's uh going back to
the first point that you mentioned and
it's something that I've heard people
talk about as well my buddies talk about
is you know the the whole idea of
post-traumatic stress and all that and
and what war does to people and one
thing that I happen to agree with is
pretty similar to what you're saying and
that
is going into the war right if the
person is got a good stable
mindset and a good attitude and is a
positive person and they're going to
come out of it with all those good
positive things Amplified they're going
to be more positive they're going to be
stronger they're going to be mentally
tougher it's the people that go into it
that are already somehow fractured those
fractures are going to get worse through
the trauma of combat again um this is a
broad generalization and there's
definitely great guys that see things or
do things that they that it it hurts
them and it takes him a while to get
through it but there's also some guys
you go you know that guy was messed up
when we showed up and now he's worse and
and it's that pressure that opens up
those fractures even even wider and it's
interesting that you got this you you
saw that with family structures as well
and I could completely see how that
happens and that happens right that
happens in it you don't even need trauma
to make that happen I mean you get the
financial trauma on a family if they're
not tight that'll that'll make them blow
up yeah whereas if they're tight you
know going through some financial
problems they'll get tighter they'll
buckle down they'll save money together
they'll skip the movies they'll start
you know they'll enjoy cooking ramen
noodles together so that trauma can can
expose those fractures that's why it's
important to try
and create the most solid foundation you
can with your family and with your own
mind so that when these traumas hit you
don't get fractured do the seals screen
for
that they try to but um you'll like this
story so we had to take a psychological
screening this is in the '90s so it
wasn't like we were super Advanced on
any of this stuff and I'm going and when
I was going through boot camp they gave
us a psychological screening for for our
attempt to go to to Seal training and so
they asked a bunch of questions and it
was complete the sentence questions and
so it would it was really obvious what
would what would flag you for and and so
I made every answer uh cuz we I was in
boot camp and the food sucked and so
every answer that I gave was just all
about food so for instance they they'd
say complete this sentence I hate when
my mother right so it's it's pretty easy
to to say you know hate when my mother
shuns me in front of my sisters and I
want to kill her no no no no all my
answers were like you know I hate when
my mother overcooks the steak and
doesn't put enough pepper on it you know
just like every answer I gave was about
food but it was really easy my point is
that it was really obvious if you were
not a complete even if you were if you
in fact if you were a psychopath you
would very easily say answer all the
questions correctly and get through it
and there's been plenty of guys that
made it through Seal training that you
know there's there's some bad criminals
there's uh there's been a couple really
heinous crimes committed by guys that
were seals and just just they made it
through they got screened so yeah they
they had a screening but I wouldn't say
it's the most effective they've gotten
better now you know and some of those
guys that committed horrible crimes it
you know kind of inspired the sealed
teams to step up that screening process
as much as possible to make sure that
we're not letting guys through that are
that are deranged some way that are
going to do something horrible like that
um you kind of already talked about
these but is there any other thing that
that you learned about
[Music]
yourself in that situation and and you I
didn't really know too much about the uh
where you went afterwards at the NIH mhm
if you want to go into that a little bit
but what did you learn about yourself
through this whole process obviously you
learned something because at some point
you decided you know what I I don't want
to I don't want to do
this
yeah I mean that's those are those are
some of the the most interesting years
of my life and I I'm pretty glad that I
didn't have my first kid till I was 35
which on the one hand you you sort of
think well God I'm so old you know like
I'm not going to be I'm not going to be
like the 50-year-old grandfather right
um but on the other hand I think it's a
really good thing because when I think
about what was going on in my mid to
late 20s you know the the sort of really
difficult decisions I had to make I mean
leaving medicine after being in it for
10 years was a really difficult decision
especially to go and do something that
had nothing to do with medicine I mean
when I left I joined a consulting firm
Mackenzie and Company and I did credit
risk modeling like I didn't have a thing
the fact that I was a doctor was like a
liability there was no like it was like
starting all over again in life um so to
get to that point yeah you I had to go
through a whole bunch of stuff so I
think
I mean I don't I wouldn't even know
where to begin I mean I think one thing
I learned was so this fellow that I
alluded to earlier Steve Rosenberg who
is again to this day probably one of the
most important mentors in my life
outside of family members um just an
amazing human being right so just kind
of on another level and I remember even
asking him after being in his lab for
two years cuz remember we had a couple
of people in the lab who I just didn't
think were that good they really bugged
me their existed bothered
me and I you know I finally after being
in the lab for 2 years worked up the
courage to ask him like how he cuz he's
like this guy who's going to win a Nobel
Prize like he's changing the game and
yet we had a couple people that I kind
of thought we Bottom Feeders and I was
like you never get upset at them like
ever I've never seen you get upset at
these people
how and he said you know Peter I just
look at everybody and I
figure out at least one thing that they
can do well and I just figure out a way
to empower them to do that one thing
even if they can't do the 10 things that
I would expect you to do I remember
thinking I understand in theory what
you're saying I can't do
that I can't tolerate mediocrity so that
was a huge thing that I learned um and
it never really hit home again until
until I was running a nonprofit because
you know there wasn't a lot of
mediocrity at Hopkins right you sort of
had your pick of the best residents
there everybody there was the best at
what they did you had amazing nurses
amazing residents amazing respiratory
therapist like everybody there was like
the best of their field right and then I
go to McKenzie same thing you've kind of
got the best of the best all over again
but you know fast forward 5 years I'm
now running a nonprofit well all of a
sudden you don't get the best of the
best anymore you you're drawn from like
the third pool and I remember coming
back to that which is you know what
you're probably not cut out to do this
you you have two choices don't be a
leader just be your own dude or be a
leader but only with a players but this
notion of like you have the capacity to
Mentor the C players and maybe turn them
into a B+ player like I don't have those
genes I can't do it and and not only
that like I will destroy the C player
and and I don't mean to but I will bury
them in the ground and and become a
horrible human to them so I also realize
like I can be a really bad person um if
I don't if I don't respect the work that
someone's willing to do so do you did
you or do you ever have to find a
counter to that cuz like if you were in
the military and you and I were working
together I would be like hey Peter you
got to get you got to get you got to act
like Rosen what is it Rosen you got to
act like him because in the military
you're not getting a players I mean you
got some great guys in the SEAL Teams
you got some great guys that are studed
you got some okay guys that are in the
middle you got some losers down at the
bottom guess what you need every single
one of them go on deployment with you
and they all got to give you what you
everything they can and the more you
create conflict with them and the more
you are talking down to them the less
they're going to do you know how they're
already a c-level player or a dle player
yeah they're going down you're not
you're not making them any better so
that's uh did you ever try and correct
that or did you just go through and say
you know what you've realized that
that's like a weak I want to be clear
there are two attributes that you can be
a c player in and I can cope with one
but I can't cope with the other and I
accept it
fully I can cope with someone who has a
C+ intellect so so if you think about
the intellect is the CPU of the computer
I don't need everybody to have the
fastest CPU I accept the fact that like
we all have different sort of innate
capacities to to to sort of process and
do and you know we all move at different
speeds I can cope with variability there
where I cannot cope with variability or
maybe I've just chosen I don't want to
is I can't cope with variability on
intent work ethic Integrity like when
you are if you can't be an a player
there I actually don't want you in my
life anymore and I think I'm old enough
now that I've just said it you know
I'm not going to deal with it anymore
life is too short and I'm not going to
deal with C players who who fail on
those metrics right I don't care how
smart you are but if you can't show up
and work your ass off if you can't be
honest if you can't care if you can't
want to get better I actually don't want
you in my life so you're right I
probably I mean I think I I'm probably
not cut out to be a leader because I
can't take those people who are failing
on those metrics and work with them well
you just need to be a leader of a very
high performing team not of a regular
regular team yeah yeah it I never had
problems right so when I was a res
resident you know residency is very
hierarchical right you know you've got
the med student the suby the intern the
seconde resident the senior resident the
chief resident the fellow the attending
I mean it's it's it's as clear as day
who's in charge at any moment in time
and as I'm going up through those ranks
for the most part I never really had
difficulty you know with the teams
underneath me but again I had the luxury
being at Hopkins everybody there is the
best the men student they're the best
the resident are the best McKenzie same
thing you know you're dealing with the
best of the best
but yeah running a nonprofit it was like
a totally different world to me and so I
think the difference is a great leader
could have succeeded in any environment
you know they could have done they could
have figured out like Okay the reason
this person like acts like a lazy sack
of is actually because of this and
you can like figure out a way to like
touch them and help them out of that and
I was just like yeah I'm not doing
it so that was so that's that's going
back to NIH and you that was the first
time you dealt with people you that's
the first time I'd sort of seen in a
long-term working environment like a
couple people who weren't top agents and
again maybe part of it's cuz you're in
the government at that point and you get
some staff people there maybe who you
know and and part of it I think was just
because Steve Rosenberg was such an
amazing guy and he could get the best
out of everybody that he might have just
had a greater tolerance for that I think
the second thing I learned was
I would never be a worldclass scientist
so when you go to NIH you're really only
going for one reason I mean I'm sure
there's some people that go there just
to check the box and say I was at the
NIH that wasn't why I went I went
because Steve Rosenberg was my hero when
I was in medical school I read his book
called The transformed cell and I was
like that book just know that book along
with another book by a guy Nam Richard
feeman called surely you're joking Mr
feeman became kind of two of the most
important books you know I read during
you know my 20s um and I actually
wouldn't date somebody I wouldn't date a
girl until she read
[Music]
[Laughter]
them yeah I'm going to we're going to go
into a after after the podcast you and I
going to go into a full full on
counseling
session you need
help so uh so so I went to NIH because I
was like look this you know this guy is
my God and like I want to be like that
right I want to be the best surgeon
scientist that ever lived and then I got
there and I realized that surgery and
science couldn't be more different
surgery is the ultimate immediate
gratification like surgery you get to
fix the problem in
hours Science is a lifetime of work a
lifetime of failure before successes in
fact one of the most remarkable stories
from Rosen B's book which of course I
read while in medical school but it
wasn't until a decade later when I'm
living it that I really understood why
he was great and why I couldn't be great
was from when he arrived at NIH in
1974 until he really had his first
success was about 10 years so for 10
years everything he was trying was
failing and every patient
died every single person that showed up
died until this one woman in 1984 when
finally they figured out how to dose
something called interlukin 2 and they
finally sort of cracked the first piece
of what has turned into a very long code
that 30 years later we're just starting
to make really amazing traction on now
think about that for a
second 43 years ago he started that job
for 10 straight years he just lost it's
like you're going to go pay pickup every
day for 10 years and lose lose every
day so what I realized was actually I
don't have that intestinal fortitude I
cannot fail that frequently and still be
at my best the next day and again I I
mean I hate admitting that because it
sounds awful it sounds like I'm I suck
and I guess I suck but like I realize
like I could be good meaning I could go
after easier problems to solve where you
can like you know get grants and you
know just play the game and that's
frankly what most people do in this
space but if you want to like change the
game if you want to change mankind if
you want to do something seol you have
to be willing
to fail
forever and I realized like I don't I
find that again it's not that I'm
addicted to the win it's not like oh I
have to be told good boy good boy good
boy but I need some win I need to know
that I have some control over my fate
whereas in surgery you have some control
over your fate
you know there is a difference between
being a good surgeon and being a bad
surgeon and it's not to say there's not
a difference between being a good
scientist and a great scientist but in
science you are far less in control of
what's going on than in surgery now he
must have had some long-term Vision
hypothesis that he absolutely he
believed he laid it out he said there
are four things that have to be true if
we're going to ever figure out a way to
get the immune system to fight cancer
these four things have to be true and if
they're not true the immune the human
immune system will never be able to
fight cancer and it took 10 years just
to figure out the first proof of concept
in a human so yes they had a couple of
successes in mice where they had
demonstrated okay like at least in mice
you can do this but in cancer biology
you know you don't get terribly excited
about doing stuff in mice for very long
you know there's a really famous Italian
uh cancer biologist who once famously
said if you can't cure cancer in a mouse
you need a new
profession like you that's that's pretty
lwh hanging fruit you you got to be able
to do it in people
so at it was while you were there that
you decided you w didn't want to go into
medicine anymore it gets complicated
right so then I decided still you still
I was still in the midst of my residency
so what I so then I went back to Hopkins
to finish my surgical training but then
I decided you know what I think I might
actually go into cardiac surgery which
I'd always been interested in so when I
was in medical school I was really torn
between cancer surgery and cardiac
surgery
and um you know to to go into cancer
surgery I think the real focus is going
to be on Research like you want to you
know you have to be involved in science
and and surgery whereas I thought in
cardiac surgery you know it's just
pretty much the coolest surgery like
it's the most technically demanding
surgery by far um I shouldn't say by far
I mean I think there are other things
that are probably on par technically but
I was like I also came back in the
mindset of you know what I'm just going
to become like a great technician right
I just and I loved operate I mean the
heart is in one sense the simp simp
organ in the body like it's really
simple to understand what it's doing you
know unlike the brain or the liver where
it's just like 10 layers of complexity
like we kind of know what's going on
with the heart and when it comes to
operating on it you know it's all a
mechanical problem like you know oh this
valve doesn't work oh this pipe doesn't
work oh this thing doesn't work um but
that was sort of my concession of well
you know what you don't have to be the
best surgeon scientist why don't you
just be the best
surgeon um because there you're more in
control right that's that's now just a
function of how hard can you want to
work um and that was that was that was
sort of right at my alley and so then
how did that path then drift to you
don't want to do any of this anymore you
know I think over the next couple of
years I mean just a couple of things
changed I mean one
was you know I wasn't getting frustrated
with these patients that we were talking
about earlier it wasn't the trauma
patients that were getting to me there
was something else that was getting to
me that was much more frustrating which
was the entire system it seemed like
everything we did was this last ditch
effort to put incredible resources
into a person's life at the very end and
we didn't really move the needle that
much right so it just seemed like a
broken system on the other end of the
spectrum there's something else that did
strike me as broken which actually
contrasts or contradicts a little bit of
what I said earlier I did feel that
there was a subtle difference in the
quality of residence so remember there
was this guy Chris on and who's like the
best resident that ever lived you know I
think I was a good resident I think
there were some other really good
residents but there were others that
just you know they were good but they
weren't great and the thing about
residency that really bugged me and I
think part of this was I was watching my
brother who was a
lawyer so he came out of law school when
I came out of medical school like we
were the same time and so I start
residency when he starts this law
practice or he joined like this law firm
and I remember
seeing that it was a a totally different
world like their promotions seemed more
Merit based like they went up the ranks
they got bonuses like all these things
happen that were a function so my
brother was like you know he was like
breaking every record at his Law Firm
right like nobody could work as hard
nobody could bill as many hours like
nobody could like crush it like he could
and he was being rewarded for it now he
ended up hating it he left he's now a
public defender or he's a prosecutor
rather so you know takes a huge pay cut
to go and become a prosecutor because
that's what he really wanted to do but
the point is he could have risen all the
way up that chain and I remember
thinking in residency I'm like we all
get paid the same we all take the same
number of years to get through it seems
crazy to me like there's no other system
where this would be the case like I I
couldn't think of another system where
you just had this complete total lack of
meritocracy um it was really hard to get
fired from residency like I saw some
real Knuckleheads do some real stupid
things I never actually saw anybody get
fired which is not to say you couldn't
I'm sure you could um
but I felt
like I was working a lot harder than was
necessary because I just wanted to be
better and I thought God it's still
crazy that this is going to take this
many years to get through so so the and
I also there was just a whole bunch of
things about the system structurally
that I thought were completely broken
and then on the other side I just felt
like healthcare was completely broken as
a system right so we have this idea yeah
I don't remember the exact stats but
you're going to spend like you know
50 60% of your entire Healthcare dollars
in like the last year or two of your
life I mean something asinine right and
uh so at the
time my wife said to
me you know you are clearly upset about
this system uh I I think you have two
choices you should either fix the system
or leave it but I think that what you're
doing now which is staying in the system
and not changing it will probably not be
sustainable and so I think the toughest
decision I ever made was at that point
cuz I'm
30 I don't know probably 32 33 I've
invested 10 years into
this and I'm thinking I want a doover I
want a complete doover which you know
everybody knows that the sunk cost
fallacy is called the sunk cost fallacy
for a reason but it's still a damn
compelling reason to keep doing
something so so that was like that was a
super difficult time and you know in
part you sort of feel like you're
letting your mentors down because a lot
of people had invested a lot in me right
Hopkins had taken me right you're I was
like one of the six chosen ones they
only take six categoricals a year so now
you're going to leave that program and
there were you know a couple of
attendings I'd become really close to
who really believed in me and really
said like you're going to you're going
to do something really special and then
to say actually I'm going to leave and
I'm not even going to be a doctor
anymore I'm just going to go and you
know so then you roll straight to
McKenzie well so I so what I wanted to
do is actually go back and get an MBA
because uh I really the other thing I
missed a lot in medicine was uh I missed
quantitative stuff like I I missed math
like I missed being an engineer and the
few times I tried to bring that into
medicine I got spanked right so there
you know there one story I I think
talked about this maybe on a podcast
before I don't think so though this is
actually probably my first or second
year I'm in the ICU taking care of this
patient and this patient's on a very
very toxic drug called gentamycin This
is a drug that has to be dosed very
carefully so if you give too much of it
you can destroy their hearing
permanently and destroy their kidneys
permanently if you don't give enough of
it the bacteria that you're trying to
kill will kill them so you're you're
you're you have a very narrow range in
which to give the dose so there is no
standard dose it's not like oh just take
875 milligrams of this every 12 hours no
it's take a first guess based on the
patient's body weight so this many
milligrams per kilogram give it to them
and then measure a level and then once
the level comes below a certain point
give it again and I remember thinking
that doesn't even make sense like surely
we know enough about the kinetics of
this drug that we could build a
mathematical model to predict when to
give it so I looked up you know a couple
of papers a couple of books one night on
call sure enough I find like there's a
very predictable Alpha and beta Decay
cycle for this drug so like literally in
Excel I build a model that uses a very
simple differential equation and it
needs a few inputs and it will predict
the kinetic curve of this and I'm like
all right let's try it out so take one
of my patients give be on jent I do
everything the standard way but I plug
my numbers into the model to see would
my model have pred predicted this better
and better and the answer was
unquestionably so now I start to get a
little confident in the idea so like the
next night I'm like all right I'm
actually going to start dosing the
patient based on the model which never
puts the patient in Jeopardy because
you're always going to check the level
before you dose but you're going to do
so at the exact right moment and so my
model predicted like at 4:31 a.m. this
patient will nater which means that's
when you need to dose them so sure
enough at like 4 in the morning I get
the I ask the nurse to draw the
patient's blood to confirm they're just
about to nater we're going to redose
them and away we go so next morning on
rounds you know on in the ICU you round
as a big team I'm presenting that you
know this patient who's one of my
patients and I start explaining that
okay so the patient received their dose
of Genty at 4:30 in the morning and the
attending says well what do you mean
4:30 in the morning we never dose gent
at 4:30 in the morning we dose it at
7:00 a.m. always and I'm like yeah yeah
yeah but the patient hit their nater at
4:30 it's like I don't care you know and
so we got into this huge fight and like
like you know I almost got fired that
that would have got me fired by the way
finally someone gets fired finally
someone gets fired and so I mean that
pissed me off beyond words right it
pissed me off that like it just struck
me as so
anti-intellectual like maybe my model
wasn't perfect I we never know but the
fact that nobody even cared to say is
there a better way to do this that drove
me batshit crazy and and that's just one
of many stories like that that happened
through residency where I was like it's
almost like we want to live in the 1950s
here and so so you have that sort of
pain of problem solving is not valued uh
at least it didn't seem valued to me was
valued in the lab but I had decided now
I'm not going to be in the lab so here I
live in this world where problem solving
is not valued and I don't actually I'm
not a Quant anymore like I don't do math
anymore and I really love loved math um
so I started so I started tutoring kids
in math I I I made like a little bit of
free time so I could like tutor high
school kids in calculus just to like get
my calculus on again missing it but it
wasn't the same so so then I was like
you know maybe I'll go back and get an
MBA so I looked into that didn't feel
like I was already drowning in debt at
that point in time you know you've got
med school debt is sort of painful and
you know residency you're making I think
at the time you're making about 34,000
bucks a year so it's you're not even
putting a dent in your $200,000 debt
sort of thing
so so then I remember one night I was in
I was on call and I was really pissed to
be on call this night this and now you
can relate to this better than I'll ever
be able to relate to it because I'm sure
this happened to you your whole life but
my best friend from high school tells me
in February he's getting married that
August and I'm the best man he lives in
Toronto so he's like this is the DAT of
my wedding I forget it was like August
5th it's a Saturday
aturday I want you to be the best man
I'm completely honored so I tell my
program director in February can I not
be on call that day or the day before I
just need to I need to be able to fly
out of Baltimore on a Friday and come
back on a Sunday and he's like yeah yeah
yeah that's no problem I remind him
three times no problem no problem no
problem sure enough the call schedule
comes out I'm on call Saturday I'm on
call the day of the guy's wedding like
you got to be kidding me so it's 2:00
that morning I'm down in the ER looking
at a a chest CT scan on a guy who I'm
worried has a what's called a dissecting
aorta and um the
radiologist you know I I introduce
myself and she's very nice and she sort
of walks me through the CT scan and and
we just start shooting the breeze a
little bit and she says oh yeah you seem
kind of down tonight what's up and I was
like ah I'm just kind of pissed off and
wish I wasn't here blah blah blah blah
blah and she's like yeah I can I can
relate I used used to be in a surgical
residency myself and I was like oh
really she goes yeah yeah I did my
internship in surgery up at the
University of Seattle and I just hated
it so much that I left and actually
joined this company called McKenzie you
know worked there for two years but then
decided I wanted to come back to
medicine so I but I wanted to do it in
sort of a Kinder gentler way so that's
why I'm back here doing radiology and I
was like huh what's this McKenzie thing
I'd never heard of it and so she told me
all about it and I was like huh that
sounds interesting how do I apply you
know and that was sort of the beginning
of it so she introduced me to some folks
and you know then I had to like study
all over again because to the way they
interview at these consulting firms is
very specific and it's not you you can
be the smartest dude in the world if you
show up and you haven't thought through
how to solve a case like what are called
these case interviews you're you're
going to flail so you have to actually
put in some leg work and and study so I
you know got a bunch of books on case
interviews and I'd be sitting in the
trauma Bay waiting for bodies to come in
I'd be like reading my cases you know
case interview things before so that
that's that was sort of the the TR
transition and then you walk you walk
you walk away from medicine you go into
so were you doing medicine specific
Consulting so I was recruited to do that
because
McKenzie um and I I'm sure this is true
of like Bane and BCG which are kind of
the other two really big um management
consulting firms um they recruit about a
third of their Consultants who out of
sort of what we call non-typical or
atypical rather um background so people
who have phds or JDS or MDS but who
didn't go to business school and then so
they send you off to do business school
that summer they do this thing called a
mini MBA which was I mean it was like
being a kid in a candy store again CU I
got to go spend a whole summer in school
again learning Finance like learning all
of these things that you know for some
people might seem kind of dry but when
you're like just dying to get back into
numbers I was like oh my God like you
know I remember the first time we
learned what was called the efficient
Frontier which is basically this
differential equation that descri
describes you know an investment
philosophy I was like like I can't
believe I'm doing this again I can't
believe it so so then I we show up for
orientation I'm in San Francisco at this
time that was the other thing I wanted
to get back to California so I was like
you know San Francisco please so during
the first uh during during orientation
week I was approached by one of the
staffers there and they said hey you
know your background looks like you've
done a lot of mathematics I said yeah
they said well you know we know you're a
physician and you're probably here to
work on you know the all the medical
teams are going to try to grab you to
have you work on some biotech thing or
whatever but um we have this um banking
issue that is is very important to some
of our clients and it requires you know
an ability to do stochastic calculus
would would you be up for doing that and
I was like of course and so then you
know that was basically the beginning
and I never really stopped doing that
stuff so so they I ended up doing what's
called credit risk modeling which then
which started out around this thing
called the bosel 2 Accord which was a
type of uh this was a regulation that
came out in the mid 2000s that required
Banks to hold a certain amount of
capital against unexpected losses so
banks have a long history of knowing how
to hold capital for expected losses but
they don't really know what to do for
unexpected losses and in particular the
problem that was damning was something
called asset value correlations so um if
you're a bank you you could have 27
lines of business you do first mortgage
second mortgage Auto student credit card
like you name it and the problem is
nobody really understood how those
assets correlated so if your loss rate
is x in this what's the probability that
it impacts the loss rate in that so
where that where the rubber meets the
road is if I can't make my house payment
I'm probably not making my car payment
either that's right and that's what
nobody got of realized everything went
down oh yeah yeah so that turned into as
we were in the midst of that because
because the banks used to leverage
themselves so much that they could well
in in when the market crashed they
weren't ready for they couldn't handle
it you know it's such an I mean it's
like literally one of my favorite topics
actually which I I'm sure your listeners
don't want to get bored to tears on it
but the first of all the best movie of
all the movies that have like tried to
explain what's going on the big short by
far does the best job because it
actually explains
the the sequence of events that went
that took this from being just an
isolated problem to a systemic problem
most people miss the subtlety of how
this thing ceased to be contained you
know cuz technically a housing crisis
shouldn't have affected the global
economy so it was these instruments
called cdos that effectively allowed
this problem to become enormous but at
the time the bigger issue
was you know just a great example of
huis that exists everywhere right which
is one we don't like looking at data
that contradict our point of view and
we're all guilty of this I'm guilty of
this I find myself doing it and I
actually I'm now quite amused I'm so
attuned to it now that I'm quite amused
like if I'm flipping through Twitter
I'll see a story that is completely
against how I feel and I don't want to
read it and then like the next one will
be like exactly how I feel I want to
read it and I'm like dude look what you
just did man you got to stop pull back
go assume you are wrong and keep going
and try to figure out if you but so so
at the at the banking level I mean and
we you know the the canary and the coal
mine here well there were many but in
200 early 2006 2000 yeah mid2
2006 we had when we were trying to do
these asset value correlations one of
the big biggest problems we had is we
couldn't we only had 10 years of data
the banks only had this data recorded
for 10 years we didn't have losses to
model and I remember saying to like you
know the controller at this bank I'm
like hey man like it's going to be
really hard to build you a model of
losses when you don't have any
historical losses and he goes well
that's mortgages mortgages can't lose
money right so that was and we can laugh
at that now but at the time that was
like not an unreasonable point of view
right like you can't lose money on a
first mortgage think about it you got to
put 20% down you want to buy a home for
100 grand you better show up with 20 you
better be able to document you have a
job you better do this you better do
that you better do that so you now the
bank's only on the hook for 80 on a home
that's been legitimately appraised for
100 and you've shown documentation so
you're at least going to pay that thing
down to 70 such that worst case scenario
market Fall by 10% house is worth 90 you
lose your job guess who still gets paid
the bank the bank they still get their
70 sure if you're in the business of
creating a second mortgage you take a
little bit more risk but there's no
reason you should have been losing money
on first mortgages and
so you fast forward a year well
especially because don't worry about the
value of the house cuz that's going to
go up always going to go up that's right
so we're good to go oh well that's where
and I remember even when I was in
Baltimore one of my buddies cuz you know
the residents were always looking for a
way to make a buck on the side right
when you're making 34k a year you got to
you got to come up with and the only
saving grace is you can't spend money
like your clothes is free you're in
Scrubs all the time you're kind of
eating for free all the time because you
I eat off the patients trays whatever
they didn't finish I'd like go to the
nurses station and eat all this crap so
I didn't I didn't actually spend much
money um pens was like the only thing I
wasted money on like I collect Mon
blancs and so even residency I would
still buy these beautiful pens so um so
yeah I remember one of my buddies being
like dude we got to start buying houses
in Baltimore because like they're so
cheap and you can get them with no money
down so you could buy a house for
200,000 bucks put like $5,000 down if
that house goes up to 220 you just made
25k you made 20K on your five we're
going all the
way and no one does the math of what if
it goes down to1 19
you just lost everything right so
luckily um I didn't get in on any of
those sweetheart deals although you know
if you time them right there a lot of
people did make a lot of money on those
deals before the shoe fell so when when
the when the when things started to
become clear so in
early in early ' 07 it became clear
subprime mortgages were going to be a
problem by August of ' 07 a a a very
famous then famous analyst what's her
name
Meredith Whitney I believe is her name I
think she was at Oppenheimer called
something that at the time seemed crazy
she said City group is going to cut its
dividend next month so for City Group
you know hu one of the largest banks in
the country to not pay a dividend for Q3
seemed impossible but she'd done the
math she's like yeah there's no way
they're they're getting crushed on these
mortgage back Securities and everyone
was like she doesn't know what she's
talking about sure enough Q3 comes along
city cuts its dividend Chuck Prince the
CEO of City gets fired and at that point
it's like God
damn but again everybody was still
thinking this is just a subprime problem
it's an inch wide and yeah it's a mile
deep but it's an inch wide well in the
background we're working on another
problem which is prime mortgages that
which everybody thinks is totally fine
that which has a historical def default
ratio of less than half a percent mhm
and we're seeing in the data the data
that was right in front of this Bank the
whole time oh there's a there's a
tsunami coming your default rate is
going to hit 4 five% which again that
might not sound like a lot that's 10
times your default rate it's going to be
actually higher than that as we learned
and your loss given a default is going
up much higher so loss is actually the
dotproduct of probability of default and
loss given default okay you guys are my
only two customers probability you
default is 50% the probability you
default is 10% if you default you will
lose 100,000 so it's 10% time 100,000 I
expect to lose 10,000 on you if you
default it's 2,000 so 50% * 2,000 1,000
so my total expected loss is 11,000 so
this is you now you do this 88 million
times for every account you have and the
model to predict probability default and
lost given default are enormous models
that each have 50 variables in them
actually the PD does the lgd doesn't but
what people didn't realize is the Lost
given defaults were skyrocketing it was
like in fact again at the level of just
being kind of a math idiot like that to
me was so amazing to watch right it was
like holy watch these lgds go
they're just like blowing up
like and then you knew once the PD
triggered meaning once the probability
of default went oh it was it was it was
going to become a
nonlinear catastrophe mhm and it turned
out so November 15th Thursday November
15th 2007 was kind of the day like that
was The Matrix moment so I had a team
great example I was able to be a leader
for once because I had an amazing team I
had a team in San Francisco of four
people I had a team in India of four
guys we worked Around the Clock 16 hours
a day every day except Sundays we took
off and we would pass the model back and
forth to each other amazing like it was
like it was it was pure Bliss to be
working that hard on this problem and on
that day we basically came up with four
independent models that all predicted
how bad this thing was going to be and
we presented it to the leadership of
this bank and it's really funny I was a
manager so so at McKenzie you have these
levels like analyst associate manager
Junior partner partner director for a
meeting of that stature meaning you're
talking to the entire leadership of the
bank the the senior partner would only
be the one to predict I'd be in the
corner working the PowerPoint answering
a question if piped up because there's
going to be a technical question but the
senior partner would do all the talking
but on that day we go into the meeting
and the senior partner says Peter you
should present this and I said are you
sure cuz I'm like the third most Junior
guy in the room here and he said yeah
two reasons one you're the only one who
actually understands how all of these
models work and two and this is the
funniest thing he said he goes two
because of all of your experience with
cancer patients you're going to be very
good at answering hard questions about
bad things happening wow and I was like
okay so I stepped in and I did my best
to be empathetic and
non-judgmental and like just as evidence
fact-based as I could and this is what
this says and this is what this when you
look at the Run rate model and the pgd
says this and the lgd says this
and the Vintage model says this and you
know here and so finally like the
president of the bank says how much
money are we going to lose like she was
kind of like you know like all good
leaders she's just like just get tell me
the goddamn answer first MH so I said I
had to think on my feet like pretty
quickly about a way to put it in terms
so I
said you're going to lose more money in
the next 18 months than you've made in
the last 10
years mhm and see the Joo answer to that
question how much money would we G to
lose would have been all of
[Laughter]
it that's the difference between you and
me on Twitter right like you always have
the best answer like always because that
that would be like Hey Jo like he just
pictured it on Twitter Hey like you know
the CEO of like the bank hey Joo how
much money are we going to lose all of
it Peter one of three well start with
your ebit da last year multiply that by
two of
three three of
three uh yeah did they did they listen
to you at all no yeah didn't want to
believe that data huh they that was
impossible that was impossible to Fathom
uh years later cuz I had by this point
left McKenzie but I stayed in close
touch with that team and I reached back
out to uh that senior partner who um
actually I'm still very close with he I
just got a mail from him two days ago um
I said hey man remember all those models
yeah yeah yeah did we were we roughly
close and he goes oh uh no the model's
underestimated by a third man I mean I
was like it seemed like we kept trying
to tone the models down because they
kept giving us these answers and we were
like damn like there's no way it can be
this bad and we were like oh let's make
this assumption more conservative and
let's do this and let's you know in the
end it was like nope it was actually
that bad brutal so then now I remember I
saw you tell a story one time it's on
it's on YouTube somewhere but you're
talking
about patient you were working on you
kind of alluded to this earlier you know
either pre-diabetic or diabetic and
you're sitting there going you got to be
kidding me cuz the day before you had
tried to save someone's life that was
you know a young kid and that was sort
of the was that the first time that you
started thinking about nutrition as a
you know and and earlier you talked
about hey we do all this stuff at the
end of life it's all this prevention to
prevent someone from actually dying but
if we would have invested some of that
money up front taught these people out
to
eat we would have been better off is
that sort of where it came from or not
at all I mean I never made that
connection at that time right so at that
time it was just what you describe it
was just the visceral reaction of I'm so
angry at you how can you not take care
of yourself how can you be sitting here
so fat so
diabetic you know over and over again
you come in here to to have these ERS de
breeded and to have these things
amputated and you know how the story is
going to go like just get it together so
so this was I mean I didn't say those
words but that's how I'm feeling right
and
so that's that's just part of like the
the callousness that developed towards
that subset of patient it wasn't
until probably
2009 um so I'm you know out of medicine
now but I was becoming overweight and I
was pre-diabetic I wasn't diabetic but I
was pre-diabetic and I was you know that
I was sort of come full circle right
that I was like wait a minute wait I do
everything right I mean I'm swimming 4
hours a day I'm following that goddamn
food pyramid to the core me I don't need
saturated fat I'm like you know I I car
blo like a banshee like why am I why is
all this stuff happening to me and so so
then when I you know went through my
whole Discovery process of figuring that
out it was only then that I really
thought back and reflected upon you know
the horrible way I had treated not just
that patient in particular but but
obviously many other patients like her
uh I remember her case specifically
because it was probably like the
absolute uh low point of my existence
um so it it unfortunately it took me
sort of failing on my own because at
least then I could say this isn't a
willpower problem it's not like you
don't care it's not like you're not
trying you're doing what you're told to
do and you're failing miserably so
either you're an outlier or maybe the
advice is incorrect so you're eating
what you're being told to eat your car
bloating and you're still getting fat
even though and at this time you're
swimming we were just talking about it
before the podcast you're doing Ultra
long swims dozens of miles worth of
swimming which by the way in Seal
training in basic Seal training the
longest you swim is 5 and a half
nautical miles which is 6.2 statute
miles which and and that's with swim
fins on so you're out there in the and
you're out there in the open ocean
swimming 12 15 18 miles at a time and
you're training for that working hard
and you're quote unquote eating right
because you're not eating saturated fat
and yet you're getting fat you going to
the doctor you get blood test and they
say oh yeah by the way you're
pre-diabetic and you just say to
yourself what is going on yeah and and
truth be told I was actually more pissed
just from the vanity standpoint at being
fat I mean you know I wish I could e is
no for those of you on the podcast Eko
is nodding his head enthusiastically to
that I mean I wish I could say like oh
it didn't bother me to be fat it did
bother me to be fat it really bothered
me to be fat right it bothered
[Music]
me it bothered me a lot actually and so
much so that I actually wanted to get a
gastric bypass and so I I
uh it's like so right now I'm about 175
I was like probably 205 to 210 oh dang
okay so once again after this podcast
you and I were going in a counseling
session um so I went to I finally got my
doctor to get me a referral to this guy
named Ken fujioka who's like a very
prominent bariatric physician here in
San Diego so I finally go to see fujioka
so I I'm sitting in the waiting room and
uh actually I think I told the story on
Tim's podcast I don't remember telling
it you did tell it but it is in it's in
the book it's in the his book I think
yeah so I but in the spirit of assuming
nobody listens to or reads multiple
other things so I'm in the waiting room
I'm finally waiting to see and the nurse
comes out and before you go back to the
to the clinic room like you have to get
weighed that's just part of the protocol
right so like they call my name so I
walk up and I get on the scale and the
nurse come out and weighs me and it's
like you know whatever 210 and she's
like
congratulations I'm like what she goes
you're post surgery right and I'm like
no I'm here to be evaluated for surgery
she like looks at me looks out at the
waiting room where everybody's 400 lb
and like doesn't say a word but the look
in her eyes is basically like what the
hell is wrong with you kid you got
serious issues
son um
but it seemed like a reasonable idea oh
yeah very reasonable very reasonable you
might want to check your reasonable
ideas with me in the
future because that is not a reasonable
idea so you get done you don't do that
surgery obviously but what he that guy
had no patience for me way what clicked
in your brain did you just all of a
sudden say to yourself okay how is this
happening and then you remembered yourp
class and said this is this is what's
happening I so I remember clear as dead
he so uh
September 7th
2009 I did a you I sort of did like one
of these long swims a year you know you
do a bunch of short ones a bunch of
training but you always I had one main
event so my main event this year was I
went back to Catalina Island and I
wanted to swim from now La out to
Catalina I had previously gone from
Catalina to LA and um it was a tough
swim I had a torn laum so about 6 hours
in you know it just became unbearable
pain um and you don't usually have a
head current in the Catalina channel so
the San Pedro Channel you know this you
probably trained out there the current's
usually running from point conception
down or up so you usually have a little
bit of a cross current rare very rare to
get anything back or forth and if
anything it's generally a little bit
towards the island and when I had
swam 4 years earlier from Cataline to La
it took 10 and 1/2 hours but that was
only 18 months after I learned how to
swim MH I was a much better swimmer in
2009 and I was going in the
theoretically faster Direction so a
great example is expectations can kill
you so I'm expecting this to be like a
9-hour swim back and and really the only
thing I'm thinking about which is the
worst thing you think about in Marathon
swimming you should never ever ever
think about how long this is going to
take cuz you just you're just setting
yourself up for misery the only real
question I had is could I break 9 hours
you know I should be able to Break N
hours right so to make a long story
short I don't even come close this is a
total disaster scenario the other thing
you you'll appreciate this just cuz
you'll appreciate the stupidity um you
never want to look anywhere when you're
swimming except down um it's very
demoralizing when you're in the middle
like if you're in the middle of the
channel you don't see Land from the
water level you just you just don't so
that's so before you get in the water
you tell the crew and every I've crew
chiefed for a lot of great swimmers I
mean it's the the the the crew asks the
swimmer what do you want what
information do you want so we're
starting the swim at midnight at Point
vente I said Okay I want to know when
there are exactly 10 miles to go and
exactly four miles to go what What's the
total distance of the swim well as a
crow flies it's
21 um and if so you don't have a current
you're doing a 21 mile swim if you do
have a current you're going to swim more
than that so so that's why I said said
guys I want to know when there's 10 to
go and four to go why 10 to go you're
just a little over halfway I'd like to
just know that at four to go it's put
your head down and swim for 2 hours
don't do anything you're there so we
start the swim at midnight this is in
September so I forget what time the sun
was Rising back then but I knew that I
would have 10 to go before the sun came
up so in other words I knew that once
the light was up I was going to be
inside the 10 stretch and one of the
most amazing things about swimming in
the middle of the ocean I don't know if
you got to experience this during
training is in the Pacific the
bioluminesence is so strong totally yeah
and so on a clear night which I was
always lucky to have every time I swam
out I've done a lot of the channel swims
every time I've been out there I've
always been blessed with these clear
nights it's so dark cuz once you get out
of LA's
light under the water so your hand is
coming down you are seeing the
bioluminescence flare off your hands
when you breathe you are seeing the
Stars you can't tell the difference it
is so dark you cannot see the difference
between stars and bioluminescence it's
like being in this amazing chamber and
so that's the that's the reward you get
for swimming at night which is otherwise
incredibly
lonely and then the first thing you
notice is the bioluminescence gets
harder and harder to see which means oh
the sun's going to be up in an hour sun
comes up now the sun's like up there I
haven't heard anything and I'm like
those guys they forgot to tell me I've
got 10 to go that's okay probably down
to six to go now and I'm swimming I'm
swimming I'm swimming it must be like
10:00 in the I mean I'm being fous it's
probably like 8:30 in the morning and
they're like 10 to go and I was like
Jesus what and cuz at that point I had
no clue what the current was like cuz a
swimmer can't feel current right
swimmers can only feel relative velocity
not absolute velocity so you know that
coupled with the torn La Brum coupled
with like it ended up being over 14
hours of swimming and this a very long
story because your question was so
simple but I remember getting on the
boat I don't even remember what my
question your question was about
nutrition about about about like when I
finally decided this I was over here in
bioluminescence Ville I mean okay so
this is the day so so finish
get back to the boat and they've got
like two burgers and two CES waiting for
me and I mean like I couldn't have eaten
those things quicker like the biggest
juiciest Burgers you've ever seen like
the cokes like they tasted so good right
because you know your mouth is so salty
like you actually really want something
sweet and my wife this you know my wife
hates when I tell this story cuz she
denies that she said it but she
completely said it um she I'm just
sitting there like I remember this I
have a picture of Burger
fatty I've got like a USA towel wrapped
around my waist inhaling like I'm two
fisting Burgers drinking my Cokes and
she just looks at me and she goes and
again just in the sweetest way possible
she said you you should probably work on
being a little less not
thin
wow I is that like the kindest way to
just tell somebody you're kind of
getting a little fat wow post 14 hour
Swim open ocean get some so that was the
last time I had a Coke yeah I've never
had Coke since dang um and and all I did
frankly at the time was just say like
I'm just going to try an experiment cuz
I was like look at that time I still
thought it was just calories in calories
out I thought it was really just simple
arithmetic and my view was all right I
can't do anything more on the calories
outside there's only 168 hours in a week
I'm not willing to exercise more than 28
of them so calories out I don't get to
change that anymore and frankly I didn't
really want to change the calories
inside cuz I hated being hungry every
time I tried to eat less I would just be
so hungry I didn't know what to do with
myself so I was like I'm going to try a
new experiment what if it's the type of
calorie that might
matter sugar strikes me as not great for
you even though I can't tell you why I'm
going to stop having sugar so that was
my first experiment in September of 09
and that led to everything that's come
since that time which obviously
ultimately led to me coming back to
medicine as well Y and that's where
you're at now and and and by the way um
Listen to Tim
Tim's podcast what else should people
listen to to get all that nutritional
information this the rest of the
story I think it's Tim's yeah I mean a
couple things with Tim um I did a
podcast with Chris creser um earlier
this year talked about longevity a
little bit I did one I did I probably
have a maybe oh you know probably get
more into nutrition on there's an ihmc
video I did probably like three or four
years ago that one's like an hour long
and you go pretty detailed in it yep
okay I've watched that one yeah those
are good those are
good and again if you had to kind
of tell people that aren't going to go
listen to those podcast aren't going to
watch that that video what would you
tell them you know what would you tell
them to
eat overall
you know I I generally don't like
talking about nutrition because uh don't
worry I will answer this question but I
I know at least preface it why I don't
like I don't like talking about this
stuff
um nutrition is kind of a pseudo science
that masquerades is a religion for many
people and so I find it difficult to
have a discussion about biochemistry
when it's so cloaked in Emotion Rel
religion and
Dogma now that's not to say I don't have
a strong point of view I certainly do
it's also an evolving point of view I
feel different today than I felt four or
five years ago uh feel different today
than I felt two years ago and also my
life is one big experiment right so you
know like we were joking before I came
in here I've got a glucose meter buried
within me at the moment I've got like
all these heart rate variability things
like everything I'm doing actually let
me just check
something I actually did an experiment
before I came here today I ate something
and I want to see how much it raised my
blood
sugar that's not bad what did you eat so
I ate this product that I've been doing
some research on it's called No k n o w
like no foods and I was introduced to
this product by one of my patients who
said hey Peter I want you to kick the
tires on this a little bit it's um it's
it uses a sugar substitute called Al
ose and it tastes amazing and apparently
like it doesn't raise your blood sugar
at all and I was like yeah I'm familiar
with allulose uh for for those who might
not know allulose is a sugar that occurs
in nature in very small quantities that
looks exactly like this sugar called
fructose which is fruit sugar the sweet
component of sugar with one small
exception but that one small exception
carries with it some very important
things one it's not quite as sweet as
fructose it's about 70% as sweet but by
giving up that little bit of that
sweetness you get a whole bunch of stuff
in return first of all it's not
metabolized by the liver which is the
real problem with fructose 2 you barely
absorb it so 99% of it or more or less
is excreted by the
kidneys and three it actually seems to
lower blood
glucose so this company no Foods is
putting this like making stuff out of
this but stuff that is like kbby like
bread and waffles and muffins and stuff
so anyway to make a long story short I'm
at this patient's house and he's Force
feeding me these things which is really
my way of saying he's left the bag open
and I'm inhaling them and he's like yeah
yeah yeah you got to you got to like
tell me if this stuff's legit so to make
it long story short he plugs me into the
guy who founded the company and he has
sent me a bunch of the stuff to just
play with cuz he knows what I do and so
that's what I've been doing so today I
normally don't eat breakfast so I worked
out this morning and then before I came
here I had a big piece of their toast
covered in almond butter and then two of
their huge waffles covered with almond
butter and bananas like I made a big
sandwich out of that so the almond
butter not going to have a huge glycemic
response cuz it's got so much fat and
protein in it but the bananas should
Skyrocket my blood sugar not to mention
the two freaking waffles the size of my
head and the piece of toast so
interestingly so that was at 9:00 that I
ate those now I've been up since 3 3:30
but I didn't eat anything I worked out
from 7 to 8 so admittedly there's a bit
of a glycogen debt so at 9:00 when I
ingested my blood glucose was
65 and at its
peak which was 11:18 a.m. it was up to
90 and it's now down to 83 what would
real waffles have done to you I think
they would have sent me to like
140 three huge pieces of bread SL waffle
with the banana so anyway I've been
doing these experiments all week which
is just a great excuse to eat this stuff
and I'm I'm actually surprised I'm kind
of blown away so okay with all that said
what's my advice for what people should
eat in an ideal world everybody would
have this thing embedded in them like I
do this thing it's called a Dexcom G5
it's a continuous glucose
monitor
um typically only used by people with
type 1 diabetes um we're now starting to
see people with type 2 diabetes wear
them but um I was really completely
lucky one day sitting on an airplane
next to a dude who happened to be into
watches I'm into watches we got talking
about watches I find out he's the CEO of
the company that makes this thing the
rest is history right I'm like obsessed
with this stuff and so because the
answer is this right if you were a
computer program I would say Jaco eat
whatever you want to eat such that your
average blood glucose remains below 85
mg per dcil and your standard deviation
below 10 Mig per decil so translate that
into English Okay so eat in whatever way
your genetics and epigenetics permit you
to such that your glucose levels stay
low and the variability stays low and
those two things will ensure that your
insulin levels stay low so what I'm
trying to do is optimize for something
called the insulin Au or area under the
curve and we can't measure that test
clinically the only way I can measure
that is put you in a hospital put a
central line in your neck and excuse me
sample your blood every 30 minutes over
the course of a day where you somehow
act normally and every day so then I'd
have a Time AIS Y axis the sorry the
x-axis would be time the y- axis would
be insulin level and we'd generate a
curve and we'd calculate the area under
that curve and we want that number to be
as low as possible so we can't do that
outside of the research setting so then
the next best thing is keep your average
glucose as low as possible and the
variability so you could have an average
glucose of 100 with low variability and
that actually wouldn't produce that much
insulin or you could have a glucose of
100 with high variability same average
glucose higher variability is going to
have higher insulin all things equal so
just through empirical testing in myself
over the past year and a half I've
realized that an average blood glucose
and this thing tells me every time I hit
click like it gives me my last 14
days I just realize like for my average
to be below 85 and my standard deviation
to be below 10 is like super dialed in
so what you can eat to achieve that
varies tremendously by individual um you
know there are some people who just
dispose of glucose remarkably so that
blood test we're going to do in you next
week is going to be our best test at
measuring that um and so so glucose
disposal is is mostly a function of the
insulin sensitivity of the muscle
because the muscle is where we dispose
of the majority of
glucose um but it's more a little more
complicated than that right sleep
impacts that right so sleep
deprivation makes us more insulin
resistant so this has been
experimentally demonstrated even with
two weeks of sleep deprivation so
there's a it's a small but very
well-controlled experiment that was done
at the University of Chicago
probably six years ago they took uh a
very small number of subjects like I say
about eight subjects and for two weeks
let them only sleep four hours a night
and they did um a very invasive test
called a ug glycemic insulin clamp at
the beginning and at the end of the
experiment and their insulin uh
sensitivity their glucose disposal
deteriorated by
50% and with no change in what they were
eating Dam so um so it's highly variable
right so that's theoretically the answer
on a practical level I would say the
answer is this right if it comes in a
package you're probably better off not
eating it right um if your ancestors
couldn't have eaten this even 200 years
ago it's probably not worth eating so if
you just followed that advice think
about how many things you'd eliminate
from your diet right if you just took
packaged Foods away right from your diet
and again notice I'm agnostic you want
to be a vegan knock yourself out you
want to be the Paleo man of the century
go for it I don't give a okay like
I couldn't care less right but if you
can largely adhere to those principles
you're kind of going to be fine do you
want you know you're going to get 70% of
the way there you want to get 80 90 100%
of the way there yeah well then there's
no simple answer now at that point you
got to dial in and you got to go full
immersion into how do you tweak to your
bio chemistry how much protein What's
the timing of the meals when do we fast
I mean all of the stuff that uh is is my
world and maybe soon to be your world uh
that that's um that's the that's the
stuff for which you cannot provide you
know systemic advice but at the at the
societal level or at the just the most
basic level yeah I mean think about that
advice like you don't you don't eat
sugar anymore you won't eat refined
carbohydrates anymore you're not going
to eat you know processed crappy Foods
anymore what are you going to eat you're
going to eat fruits you're going to eat
vegetables you're going to eat meat
you're going to eat grain you know what
kind of grains are you going to eat well
you know you're you're you know you're
not going to really eat these sort of
refined crappy grains that people eat
you're going to you know your your
starches I'm sorry not grains your
starches are probably going to be in the
form of potatoes and rice so again a lot
of you know again I just I sort of I
think the reason I don't like talking
about nutrition anymore is I don't find
it to be an intellectually honest
discussion anymore I find it to be just
a discussion of Dogma right so if you're
a low carb Camp you're a low carb Camp
if you're in the
you know whatever the vegan Camp you're
in the vegan camp like there's that you
can't even have a discussion about this
stuff and at least not with most people
yeah so I just you know you ever read
the book called diet Cults I know
so you just said right there that's the
whole book really so interesting fun to
read too so good I will have to check
that out diet Cults now I kind of open
with this and since
we're since we're a little over two
hours right now come on uh I said that
you're probably the most responsible
individual for this
podcast and because you originally
through
Kirk uh set me up to do a podcast with
Tim Ferris which sent me up to do a
podcast with Joe Rogan which was just
all awesome and both those guys told me
I should do my own podcast so anyone
that's listening to this podcast say
thanks to Peter for that actually they
should thank Kirk right because and Kirk
was the man you know I mean Kirk is I
don't need to tell you but Kirk's one of
those guys where like he doesn't have to
justify and ask right so when he
introduced me to you he didn't have to
explain he was just like I want you to
meet jao jao's my friend like that's
good enough and so you know to me like
that's the measure of when life is good
and because I feel that way with all of
my friends like if Tim introduces me to
somebody like Tim's introduced me to
like a dozen people a dozen amazing
relationships have come out of that
right and so you know you know really it
was just very easy for me to sort of
take Kirk on his word that like if you
know if joo's a great guy then that's
that's all I need to know I knew you're
going to be a great guy and then
similarly like I could tell Tim like hey
you got to meet Joo and and you know Tim
gets quote unquote pitched all day long
yeah he does but you know he knows that
I'm I'm not going to send him somebody
that's not you know going to be really
interesting and going to benefit his
listeners not just you know whatever
agenda that person might have yeah yeah
no it was awesome and that that really
did I mean the way
Tim the way Tim advised the way he was
going to release the podcast in order to
support the book I mean he just nailed
it it was kind of ridiculous the way he
understands that stuff and how how
helpful it was to you know getting our
book out there and getting it sold and
and all that and getting all these
people on board and then you know that
turned into this podcast which you know
he he definitely has promoted the
podcast in a fantastic way along with
Joe so that's both been awesome but
again started with Kirk connecting me
with you and then you connecting me with
Tim so uh appreciate that and um
speaking of this
podcast my almost Silent Partner over
here Echo Charles if somebody wants to
support the
podcast how would you recommend they go
ahead and do that you always wait I have
a question
oh oh how'd you hurt your back
originally you know I don't think we
ever really have a diagnosis there was
certainly nothing on that day that I did
that day I'm riding my bike to the to
the gym I I you know I think about the
sins of my youth um you know I was
really into martial arts in addition to
boxing and I used to spend a ton of time
um I was really obsessed with spinning
back kicks now I don't know if that
could have done it or not I but I used
to practice 75 spinning back kicks with
each leg every single day for probably
about six years 7 years um it's possible
even though in theory a spinning back
kick if done correctly should really not
put any torque on the lower back it's
much more in your hips and technically
the flexibilities in the thoracic spine
not the lumbar spine but you know God
knows maybe I just wasn't doing those
things correctly um I did Squat and
deadlift really heavy growing up I did
powerlifting as sort of a side sport but
you know certainly never hurt myself
doing that um I rode crew for a year and
so I always I've always wondered if that
was the most destructive thing I did
because um in an eight-man boat it's a
you're asymmetric right so when you
skull you're symmetric when you sweep
you're not and so I was like I was a
sweeper and so I almost wonder if like
that's the most destructive thing I ever
did yeah and then You' figure if you're
asymmetric like that your everyday life
is asymmetric really cuz you have a
little bit of over development on one
side that that might have been so I
guess I've never really known but I take
it really seriously today in fact you
know jao you'll dig this um two weeks
ago I I did a video in New York with a
friend of mine named Jesse schwarzman
and uh he's like I call him the Savant
of movement this guy's like just like
the kinesthetic man and um I wanted to
put a video together of how do you train
to train how do you prepare your body to
train so it's basically three sections
it's um what uh what What's the sort of
dynamic well the the sort of tissue
preparation the static prep and the
dynamic prep it took us eight not may
maybe six hours to shoot this video
it'll be edited down into probably three
10 minute videos and as soon as they're
done editing I'm just going to throw
them up on YouTube and my blog so I'll
make sure you've got a copy awesome it's
it's it's I mean Jesse's just uh you
know he walks me through all the
exercises but I get the sense like if I
had done that stuff all the way in my
life I probably never would have been
hurt and luckily knock on wood to this
day I mean I never thought I'd be able
to squat and deadlift again after going
through that year of my life but
amazingly I I'm totally fine and it was
a herniated disc that popped off yeah so
it was an L5 S1 really big herniation
but then a four or 5 cm fragment broke
off and then floats down the canal and
that was sitting on the nerve route and
then I developed a few other problems
after so I developed this thing called a
facet arthropathy which resulted in the
feeling of having my testicles torn out
from the inside I'm not even joking
that's just so it's just unbearable yeah
I would imagine that's unbearable I
don't recommend that no all
right um well that being said I guess we
can talk about
um guess we can talk about on it I was
talking with Greg mhm and Terry mhm and
I was showing them uh I was showing them
the warrior bars right these are these
are dope and then then he was like oh
yeah like what else is there there some
good stuff on it has good stuff so I
brought out the that new pre-workout one
which is good by the way I have a report
on that so that one comes out and then
uh the K oil comes out oh yeah this is
good for this so we're talking about
this this big table of like all the sub
it's not a lot it's like four things the
worry bar the Crill oil and the
Pre-Workout and uh three things and
we're like yeah this does this and this
does this and then I kind of steep back
and I'm like yeah we're those guys with
all our supplements talking about
supplements talking about supplements
right which I've never done and Greg
goes yeah if we weren't such nice guys
this would be a real douchy conversation
so the kind of the irony there is him
saying that he's the one having the
douchy conversation but he is the nice
guy you get it I I guess so anyway point
there or actually the second point there
is on it is good supplement so so if you
do talk about them while you're taking
them you're not having a douchy
conversation and this is why I heard Joe
Rogan talking the other day about like
how hard it is when you're a stand-up
comedian and you tell a joke and it's
just flat yeah I think we just got a
yeah but that wasn't here's the thing
here's the thing that hurt me there
there were I was give you a mercy laugh
but I didn't do it cuz I'm not a
merciful person that was that had joking
elements but this is true and this is
part of a bigger point that I'm making I
hope so I expect you to laugh at
everything I say even though you pretty
much do
anyway the reason that it's not a douchy
conversation here's the point is because
on it supplements acry oil all that
stuff is actually good quality it's not
like hey I'm going to meet it I'm going
to get buff and all this stuff it
actually helps your performance anyway
so in the event of you wanting on it
stuff and supporting this podcast while
at the same time supporting yourself go
to on it.com 10% off
boom so second way to support Amazon
click through Christmas is over but we
still need stuff duct tape whatever
knives Etc um if you want to support
this podcast just go to the website chop
podcast.com click through the on the um
Amazon Banner link before you do your
shopping you can support that way it's a
good way to
support oh wait yeah you're into
chemistry right sodium when you put a
little piece of sodium in the water
right it makes this big commotion so
that's what kind of what the Amazon
clickthrough does it seems like the
small little thing but applied properly
it makes a big impact in the podcast
support-wise anyway thought you'd get
that can we verify that doctor I will
have to go and look at the Amazon
clickthrough to
confirm I I tell Jo you typically
doesn't really understand cuz he doesn't
know what sodium does no might have been
potassium or both actually actually so
now this whole thing's been a lie or
unsure no no no I'm pretty sure I'm
actually fairly certain pretty sure goes
a long way with that go I guess yeah
anyway you can subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes which seems obvious CU
typically the the podcast you listen to
you subscribe to but sometimes you don't
so subscribe if you have
not already and you want to support this
podcast Google play Stitcher also in the
game
yeah and iTunes yeah yeah it's kind of
unfair that I don't think about that as
much you know when you have an iPhone
like you kind of forget all this other
stuff over here to help out yeah man
good thing you're you're here yeah on
this podcast um YouTube of course we're
working on putting more videos on there
aside from the whole podcast so some of
those videos and I have gotten like
messages saying like those shorter Clips
are helpful they are helpful you know
rather than listening to the whole
podcast there's been people that there's
been people that have been submitting to
you on Twitter which excerpts yeah are
in high demand out there in the world
yeah yeah I've been following now in
fact I have them all like it's a it's a
process but yeah we're working on that
so subscribe to YouTube we are working
on that we are like it I like it
collectively just so you guys know I'm
not working on any of that but Echo
apparently is which is cool well
technically you saying hey Echo put this
one up okay boom did your yeah
exactly um and then in the event of you
wearing like what like a t-shirt or
something or a hoodie Joo has a store
it's called Joo
store the URL is Joost store. is that a
is that a calculator watch you have I
was going to get to that so you
mentioned see now we got to change the
subject real quick which I like by the
way remember you were talking about your
into watches yeah right I was going to
show I didn't want to interrupt what
you're saying but that is you appreciate
that right that is
ridiculous I just reincorporated uh this
one back cuz what is it a calculator
watch cat watch actually one of the
first pictures I posted on Twitter was
up before the eneme and it was like you
know jock was always like yeah 4:30 a.m.
which one is that the Casio yeah Casio
schol dude Circa
85 that watch when I was a kid dude like
I would have killed someone for that
only the cool kids had the calculator
one usually if you had a watch was just
the regular Casio and the cool kids had
the calculator I had the
first Iron Man did you yeah it was black
with like a little red trim on it I
asked for it for Christmas my parents
got it for me but I knew where they hid
presents so every day after school I
would go into their room and I would
take it out of the box and I would I had
set the time I would wear it I would
just hang out there and then before i'
go to bed I'd like sneak back put it in
and so like on Christmas day it was like
i' been wearing the watch for a month
right right those was your
watches actually I think you got a got
I'm in watches too yeah yeah well I got
one I actually got I got quite a few of
these you should have your own brand of
watches yeah we'll see how all that
turns out
yeah nonetheless yeah I am very proud of
this calculator
watch back to the store though Joo store
no watches but yet there are yet yeah
not yet but there are some cool shirts
in my opinion I think they're discipline
equals Freedom all these things joo's
head good written in backwards various
layers to these shirts not just like oh
a picture that's
it so if you like any of that stuff I'm
not even saying go buy this stuff I'm
not saying that just go to the Joost
store.com see if you like it if you like
it you want one then you buy one and
that supports the
podcast you know it's a systemic
thing good
there you go patches on there as well
rashguards you know what you didn't
mention that you should have mentioned
cuz apparently it's been pretty cool out
there in the world lay it on me
psychological
warfare yeah I didn't mention it this
time but I mentioned it last time and in
my everyday life and I use it so there
you go psychological warfare you use it
I use it every day when needed here's
the thing you can't use it every day no
you can't actually you can I'm not going
to say you can't use it every day but
the reason the whole reason that I was
like Hey Jo what do you say you know
when
you're I don't need it every day okay
but it varies you know from season to
season so like you know Christmas time
if if you are coming up against moments
of weakness yep we have a little method
to get you over those humps yeah would
it's kind of like coaching a little bit
because you Psychopathic coaching yeah
yeah psychop for sure
it cuz it kind of at I play for I played
one of them for my seven-year-old
daughter the other day cuz she was about
to eat some candy or something I was
like come here for a minute yeah so I
played her that one you know the the
snack time one sugarcoated lies yeah
sugarcoated lies she was she was pretty
impressed but what impressed me was
later in the evening she was kind of
saying it yeah I was see and that's what
I was going to say where you explain
it's like cool it's Joo telling me to do
this so yes I'll do it or not do it or
whatever but you explain some some some
good stuff like to to remember you know
like it is sugarcoated lies yeah and
that's kind of catchy too so it sticks
in your mind
poison so you can buy that on iTunes
it's somewhere else too right Google
Play if you want it and also everyone
that asks for an alarm tone to wake up
that's it that's it it's there now you
don't have to ask anymore you can just
go to iTunes and get that psychologic
clear it with your wife though or
whoever you sleep with yeah we've gotten
some serious feedback on that one yeah
because what happens is the alarm goes
off if you have it set then it's going
to be my voice and it's going to be
weird cuz sound like there's some
strange man in your room at 4:30 in the
morning which is kind of weird yeah does
the alarm only work at 4:30 a.m. like no
it's just it's just a it's just a it's
an album it's it's an album of tracks
and each
track talks about some moment of weak
generally a moment of weakness that you
have like there's ones to wake up in the
morning
there's ones to you know what you don't
feel like going to the gym go to the gym
there's ones you feel like eating a dut
don't eat the donut there's one oh I'm
going to I'm going to put this off for a
while I'm going to procrastinate no
you're not going to procrastinate so all
the little moments of weakness that we
all have as humans can be countered
using psychological warfare factually
yeah there's there's actually two on
there there's one called like I think
it's called like no more it's basically
like I'm not doing this anymore no more
is a good one that one's good because it
puts in towards exactly like what you
want to think like you cuz you always
feel that like you know how like you
know you're gaining some weight or I
mean a lot of times you know why you're
gaining weight and so it's a little bit
different but you're like you know what
I'm not doing drinking is one where you
wake up kind of hung over and you're
like I'm not drinking anymore you know
like that thing but you never really
execute yeah you know man it's perfect
cuz it sticks with you you're like no
more and then the other one was um when
you're talking about every day it's
called every day I think every day every
day a Monday that guy that one that
one's dope man so you can get after that
also if you want to get some tea if
you're a tea drinker or if you're not a
tea drinker you can get some Jocko white
tea you can get it on Amazon it's fully
in stock y'all those days of being out
of stock I think we've got them under
control for now and I won't make any
promises cuz last time I made a promise
you guys went psycho so I'm not going to
make a promise but you can get the Jocko
white tea I figured out again it doesn't
it doesn't taste like like
tea really it doesn't taste like coffee
and for a long time I was at a loss for
words to describe what it tasted like
and I figured it out I was responding to
someone and I figured it out what it
tastes like and it's pretty simple the
jocka white tea tastes like
Victory so if you need to and we need to
trade I need to trademark that one stat
the fact that Jo White Tea tastes like
boom so get some of that if you need to
deadlift more if you need to overhead
squat more weights this will increase
all those numbers beyond anything you
could have hoped for you can drink it
from a Joo mug says get after it on it
that's good oversized by the way yeah
it's big it's big it's not somebody
somebody made the comment that it's not
comically big right it's not a joke yeah
it's not like clown shoes no it's not
clown no no no
but it's big enough to you know it's big
like a pair of work boots it's as big as
a pair of work boots it will kick you in
the ass if needed yeah so it's that big
if you haven't got the book extreme
ownership you can pick that up there
it's about leadership it's about combat
leadership I'm going to give my friend
Peter AA about three copies of it just
to make sure he reads it so if he has to
deal with any c players he's going to
step up his game a little bit hopefully
I read a pre-publication copy but I
clearly missed that wait what's up preu
what does that mean meaning before the
book came out hey here's what the book
is okay but it's still that's it that's
you got the pre paperback yeah yeah was
like you got the VIP pre screening Dam
yeah yeah um hey speaking of extreme
ownership we're having another muster if
you don't know what it is check out the
website extreme ownership. comom it's
going to be in New York city so everyone
can come cuz if you're on the East Coast
no matter where you are on the the world
it's easy to get to New York
and May 4th and 5th if you're a leader
or you want to be a leader come and get
it there's every level leaders there
CEOs midlevel managers every industry
you can think of too you have people
that manufacturing and finance and
construction and health and
pharmaceutical and there's police there
and fire and Military and oil industry
and energy everybody all working on
leadership talking about leadership So
and I've said it's going to sell out
we're moving in that direction quickly
and Ekko hasn't even released his videos
yet cuz he's on Hawaiian Time no no oh
you're not no I'm I'm working diligently
and I'm going for quality not you know
you're not going to put out any scrub
material right once those videos come
out my feeling is it's going to sell out
very quickly so get there now sign up
for it if you need a police or a fire
discount or a military discount or if
you're going to bring a group of people
I think the biggest group we had at the
last one from one company was around 16
people from one company or 12 people but
there's some pretty big numbers of
companies that are showing up there come
and come and get it Eko you got any
closing
comments my pleasure uh no other closing
comments thank you other than it was
your pleasure Peter any closing comments
I would only Echo echo's comment and
that didn't even get planned until it
came out perfect perfection and if you
want to continue these conversations
with Peter on Twitter you're Peter AA
MD what are you on
Facebook um I don't know probably uh do
you still have eating Academy yeah yeah
it's probably the is I I don't I don't
do a lot so Twitter's your most Twitter
prominent and I've been berated into
doing something on Instagram I just
can't cope at the
moment yeah there's a way to connect the
two I've tried it I don't like it I do
them separately yeah you don't really
connect Twitter to the Instagram I think
it's the other way around well there's a
way to connect some of them somehow yeah
I just don't have enough pictures to
show right I don't have anything to talk
don't you have a bunch of watches yeah
but see I'm showing a watch the same
watch every day show that ring how you
were explaining it true bad ass R you
could do like 12 pictures just on the r
what if my what if my whole Instagram
shtick became this like my blood glucose
at every moment that'd be pretty cool
and you kind of what you ate you could
just you could just uh save that screen
and post it up there so much work it's
it's work it's hard labor to save that
thing and press submit to it actually
has a little switch that you can just
make it go it's not that much work all
right I'll think about it for somebody
that's swimming 18 miles in the oan talk
about too much work to post an Instagram
picture you got issues
son
uh all right Eko and I we are also
present and accounted for on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and
also if you're going to be looking
around that face bie boha we going to be
there Echo is at Echo Charles and I am
at Joo willink and again I would like to
thank you Peter for coming on and more
important for everything you've done for
me which really the way it's connected
all together getting me through Kirk to
Tim Ferris which was the book and
getting me on Joe Rogan which led to
this podcast it's been awesome so to you
and to Doc Kirk parsley for introducing
us but thank you and him for what you
guys have done for me so men and women
in uniform out there holding the
line thanks for your service and your
sacrifice to the police on the
corner fighting crime the firemen
fighting fires thanks for keeping us
safe to the
medical people in the medical
professions like Peter doctors nurses
Physicians assistants EMTs all of you
working to save lives thank you for your
commitment to service and it's obviously
a massive commitment when you hear about
the
hours and the emotional trauma that it
takes to go into any one of those
Industries and
services and to everybody else that's
listening thank you it's your
Communications your questions your
participation your feedback and your
spreading of the word that makes this
possible and it's what makes this
worthwhile so thank all of
you for all of
that and finally thanks to all of you
for getting out
there and getting after
it so until next time this is Dr Peter
Atia and Eko and
Joo
out